all right people the internet is about
to crash and sjw heads are about to
explode this is our second live stream
of the day i've already put in two hours
of work people but we're back and i am
sitting here i can't believe it's a live
human being carl benjamin aka
sargon of akkad how you doing man
tired really really tired the journey
the the journey over was long and
stressful but it's good to be here you
flew across the pond
yeah how did that go for you it was fine
actually it was a night the journey
wasn't uncomfortable it was just really
long and let's get up really early and
stay up really late all right let's
start with with first things first i
think a lot of people
although you do show your face now yeah
okay pretty frequently and you do other
shows and live streams and all that
stuff i don't think people are really
used to seeing the human know you know
carl they they think of this this sargon
fella are carl and sargon the same
person deep right off the top yeah i
don't have a persona or anything so i i
you know it's just
sargon was my gamer handle that i always
used to use when i was playing video
games with my friends and it was just
you know i i you know just used it to
register on whatever websites i was
using and i registered my youtube
account about three years before i even
thought about posting a video yeah
i never
reconsidered changing or anything
because i never thought anything was
going to come of it if i thought that
one day i'd be sat here talking about
things i probably would have just used
my name right but i it just never
occurred to me and now i'm here and now
i'm stuck with the labels
it's too late you can't change your
youtube it's all right i like the name
you know i like the i like the
historical figure so it's fine it's just
not what i planned because i didn't plan
anything so we've discussed a little bit
you've been on twice before uh once once
you really helped me out because we were
in between studios we did a little
google hangout thing you're a good man
uh
and we've discussed some classical
liberal stuff and a bunch of stuff that
we're going to get into but for people
that have no idea who you are
why did you start making political
videos
i was disturbed by the amount of
nonsense i saw from the regressive left
in the media it was um it was a lot less
then than it was now than it is now yeah
um but even then this was like three
probably four years ago now where i was
just
i was constantly just seeing this
nonsense and it wasn't just the
regressive left it was it was many
things but it
i was honestly just
at the point where i was thinking okay i
can see what's happening i can see why
i'm not happy with it and i have the
choice to either do something or not do
something and my conscience just
wouldn't let me sleep i couldn't i
couldn't just do nothing yeah and i
don't
i never wanted to do any of this
i don't i don't want to be like a public
figure i don't want to have a media
presence i don't want any of that but it
just
i felt like i had to you know i had to
do something and
three years later now here i am yeah so
we'll get to some of the stuff that you
were seeing that you didn't like what
were your political leanings before all
that oh i've always just considered
myself a liberal um
definitely not the american version of
what a liberal is yeah yeah yeah in
britain
you're talking about sort of um
the sort of lockheed thomas paine sort
of liberal you're not you're not talking
about the progressives who come from a
fundamentally as f
as far as i can make out because i'm not
even sure they're that certain of their
own beliefs
it seems to be they have a set of goals
in mind but don't really know how they
plan to achieve those goals through an
ideological framework
and so when they they come out and have
to advocate for things like
um
affirmative action you know that is
completely illiberal to advocate for
just an end equality because i mean
for a liberal to say that i want an
equality of outcome is the anti
antithesis of what liberalism is it's a
quality of opportunity and from a
quality of opportunity you are going to
see an inequality of results and that's
the point because an equality of result
means that someone somewhere isn't
getting what they want they're being
artificially restricted by someone else
whoever's setting the rules you should
see a natural diversity of thought
opinion and outcome when you are
operating in a liberal system so to
artificially weight it
is well illiberal and i didn't like it
so when i was uh
waking up out of the progressive coma
and i started just tweeting a few little
things that i thought were wrong and
this is about about three years ago i'd
say
suddenly the internet started all at
once talk to sargon
talk to sargon you were really the first
person that they said this is the guy
that's online talking about this stuff
and then you had me on your show which
uh you had a much bigger audience than i
did at the time it helped me get some of
my bass so i so first off i thank you
for that um but did you realize that
talking about basic classical liberal
john locke you know on liberty values
was going to be thought of as somehow
controversial or something because in an
odd way it is in some bizarre sense
there's
how to put it um
i didn't think it was going to be
controversial i i honestly thought that
i would
i would get a lot of positive responses
from the people who were doing these
things because i because they called
themselves liberals and so i was like
well why are you doing things that are
going against the core values of
liberalism and
it's i mean at the time i wasn't even
particularly well read in liberalism i
didn't really know very much about it
but i knew i knew the sort of outcome of
liberalism and i knew the the principles
but i didn't know the intellectual
history of it
and so i had to educate myself on that
obviously
and i think that what progressives
really need to ask themselves is do they
want equality opportunity or do they
want equality of outcome because that is
the the core difference between
liberalism and progressivism and i think
that a lot of them think a lot of people
i mean i hear people saying i'm a
liberal progressive it's like what does
that mean
you know and i think what the problem is
is they've got a certain set of
overlapping magisteria where they want
things like tolerance that's a perfectly
respectable thing and a liberal wants
tolerance but tolerance for a liberal is
the consequence of the principles that
they're operating under whereas for
progressives it's the goal of their
principles so they are quite happy to
say restrict someone's freedom to apply
for a job is is a really
classic one in order to achieve what
they consider to be a tolerant end
but that to me is not tolerant thing i
mean for example the bbc at the moment
uh ever and for anyone who doesn't know
is the uh state-run uh media corporation
of britain
they
and this is my my taxpayer money goes to
this my license money goes to this they
actively discriminate against white
people on in in hiring for their jobs
and it's not all the jobs obviously but
they have certain jobs where they will
literally say this is for and the term
in britain is black and minority ethnic
but it basically means non-white
uh for being only and it's like
i'm sorry what
on what planet do you think it's
acceptable to turn around and say you
know what you're the wrong race to apply
for this job and the things if it was
for a job say in front of the cameras or
something like maybe
i could bend my principles enough to say
okay fine you know i can accept that but
i mean for the exactly what would be the
purpose of that just just to be clear so
you'd want just so that there would be
some
sense of diversity on what we're
actually seeing yeah i mean i i i i can
tell you're not you're not thrilled with
that no i'm not yeah but i i could at
least accept it and say well okay you
know i i can understand your reasoning
and i'm not so offended by but but this
is for like a researcher behind the
scenes and it's like no i'm sorry
there's no reason
in in my political lexicon that you can
give that is acceptable i i don't find
that acceptable um and so this is this
is the question do you want a quality
outcome do you want quality opportunity
and i want quality of opportunity and
not outcome yeah and the progressives
want the opposite
so you've obviously in this 10 minutes
or so here have said nothing racist or
bigoted or anything like that but there
is a because of the way that the
progressives are using
race
there's a racial connotation to all of
this
and i what was it i think it was was
there an article written about both of
us or something tweet on something there
are many hints
somebody was calling you a white
nationalist or a white supremacist or
something i wish i could remember the
specific instance of it i and i remember
pushing back on it of course
but but
therein lies part of the problem that
that our education i think for both of
our countries is so screwed up right now
that when you say these sort of very
obvious things about equality of
opportunity versus outcome which
everyone should be on board if you truly
care about equality
people think that's somehow a racist
this is something i thought long and
hard about so
for example when they say
we want to see
we want to have a job that's so open
only to say i'm just going to use the
terms white and black but i mean
non-white and white yeah
they're only open to black people then
you ask them okay what's the rationale
for that well black people are
disadvantaged they're often very poor
they come from difficult families and so
okay well why don't we just open that to
people who are disadvantaged and poor
that's something we can qualify very
easily we can we can figure out who's
poor by simply looking at their
paychecks look at them you know
monthly income so the issue is not
actually the race the issue is the
financial situation of the person so why
discriminate against the white people on
the basis of their race if the problem
is that they're poor
the problem isn't that they're poor the
problem is that they're white and the
other ones are the problem you know the
the favor in the progressive mind is to
go on to the people who are black purely
because of the perceived disadvantages
of i guess being black which to me
sounds like a racist thing to say which
i mean
exactly you know i i don't look at a
black person think well you're probably
disadvantaged but that's them i mean
what i'm advocating for i guess maybe
it's because it's outside of the
paradigm because what i'm advocating for
is
a racial you know it's it's not i don't
want their race to be a factor on which
they are judged and yet these people
can't seem to separate that from the
situation that we're talking about and
so
if i'm saying look
you should be judging people on maybe
something that is more controllable or
maybe something that is more relevant
like i mean financial situation is
something that is genuinely relevant and
it affects black people white people red
people whoever you know
it's if that becomes the category that
you focus on then you can help people
without racial prejudice
being a factor in your own decision
making and that's the thing like every
time you discriminate in favor of
someone on the basis of their race
you're also discriminates other people
against them on the basis of the race
yeah and that to me is what racism is so
but isn't the interesting piece of that
is that i think the people that that
hold this ideology they don't mind that
kind of discrimination they think
actually that that discrimination they
wouldn't call it discrimination but they
they think that that discrimination is
actually positive
because there's a certain set of them
that think that the white man or
whatever or the patriarchy should be
punished
right this yeah this comes down to um
the problem the the root i think the
root problem of most ideologies
and the
sort of
public conception of them is the
redefinition of a certain term almost
every ideology if you look at them
and you look at them in detail they'll
come down to a redefinition of a term
for example um
freedom is one of these terms for
classical liberals that a lot of
many many classical liberals define
freedom like libertarians always define
it as freedom from
not freedom to
um but the the way many classical
liberals will
some at least will describe it as being
oh it's what you consider to be
something to be free from for example i
mean poverty can well be considered an
oppressive force you can you can measure
the oppression of poverty um there are
you know many studies that show it
decreases your iq decrease your lifespan
all these other and decreases various
opportunities it puts you in a lower
class and and when you go into a lower
class you you end up finding yourself
with inherent disadvantages just because
of your mannerisms and the way you speak
that you know i mean for example if you
see someone like francesca ramsey uh i'm
sure a lot of people know who she is
from mtv she's incredibly well spoken
yeah incredibly well read she's an
intelligent woman she's not lower class
but if you take someone like um
you can find almost anyone on live leak
for example one of these sort of videos
that you see going around with right
people brawling
none of those people will ever get a job
on mtv and it's not because they're
black because mtv's happy to have black
people it's because they're poor and
they're lower class
um
so i can't remember what your question
was now of course well so so from so
from that though what are the
what are the basic liberal classical
liberal beliefs that you have like what
do you think sort of encompasses what
the modern classical liberal right okay
so
um
okay so
one of the
i mean i personally want to see everyone
treated
as equals i mean the the the for me what
i interpret classical liberalism the
core principles and the the ethos behind
it is to create a brotherhood of man
effectively a system of peers and equals
because it came out of a time when there
was an aristocracy and it was the the
problem was the aristocracy oppressing
almost everyone else in society i think
this is the reason i find
the social justice warriors so offensive
because what they want to do is turn
their minority status into power over
you
they want to turn themselves into a new
aristocracy where on the basis of the
fact that there aren't very many of them
and they have a distinguishing quality
between them
then everyone else has to obey their
rules and i'm sorry that's not
acceptable to me what has to happen is
they have to obey the rules of my
majority and if they can't put
themselves in the rules of majority then
i'm sorry but we can't just remodel
society for the whims of a small group
of people because that creates an
aristocracy and i that fundamentally is
what classical liberalism is about in my
opinion so why did these ideas which are
hundreds of years old of of classical
liberalism why did they get buried to
the point that when i started waking up
to this stuff that people were going oh
you got to talk to sargon because you
weren't talking about youtube and not
like why wasn't there someone else like
a mainstream person that they could have
been like that's
this guy's been talking about that
forever instead they're telling me to
talk to you because i don't know i i
mean
it could be that it's the
the water we swim in and so you know
fishing water probably doesn't have a
word for water you know that sort of
principle yeah it could well be that we
are so subsumed in it we just take it
for granted and we don't really realize
this sort of creeping degradation of it
until suddenly we're looking at racial
quotas and racial discrimination in
public uh organizations and things like
this
i mean i i honestly i don't know why
it's ended up this way i know
i mean
there are so many problems i think that
the
i think the i mean i imagine many of
them stem from the quality of
universities at the moment uh leaving
the stem fields aside of course there
there seems to be a nascent socialist
revolution brewing at our universities
and that to me is highly disturbing in
the same way that an islamist revolution
is disturbing when it's brewing in the
mosques yeah you know it's not all of
them it's some of them and it's
indoctrinating enough of them that it's
becoming a real problem this is why we
see
i mean hundreds of anti-far members clad
in black all from the middle class all
university educated all absolutely
terrible at fighting each other and we
see them in the streets and they feel
justified they think this is all
completely within
their their right to do this and they
think they're going to create a better
world at the end of it and the irony of
it is you can't point to a socialist
system that's successful that that's
ever worked there there's always an
excuse why that one oh yeah that wasn't
the real no it wasn't the real one that
one wasn't the real one do you think do
you think we're at a particularly
strange precipice in the world right now
where this battle between
all of this post-modern stuff and
cultural marxism and sjw stuff versus
those of us that are really
you know somewhere in the middle trying
to explain what freedom is versus the
authoritarians on the right that because
of the internet because of globalization
that actually the whole system of the
world seems like it's it's in a
precarious place a moment is that is
that alarmist
i think that we've come back to the
cycle of history i mean if you look if
you look back a hundred years ago we're
looking at the russian revolution it's
not it's it's not particularly different
you know and you've got the alt-right
and you've got the anti-fire crew
fighting in the streets this is
something straight out of the road to
serfdom hey it talks about how the nazis
and the communists fought in the streets
of germany until the nazis eventually
won and let's be honest with you if you
think it's going to come down to an
actual fight between the alt-right and
the anti-far
uh socialists who do you think is going
to win that it's not going to be
anti-far they're weak
they're
absolutely weak they don't know what
they're doing i mean they've got this
fantasy conception of how they're going
to bring in some glorious socialist
revolution it's not going to happen
right there's no there's no strong
foundation of an ideology
there is a huge deep strong foundation
and the worst you think for those
average people that are out there oh not
from the alt-right no for the so for the
uh anti-farm yeah but you think those
those anti-fog people really i'm talking
about the ones that are out there with
the masks and the bats and everything
you think they really have an
understanding of what politically
they're playing absolutely i mean you've
i mean many of them are professors like
you've got eric clanton who was arrested
people probably know him as the uh the
masked anti-far protester who hit some
random chap over the head of the bike
right right that guy's a professor you
know or a lecturer at a university in
and he i mean on his like uh on his
dating profile he he put his interest as
being revolution it's like dude you are
not you are revolting it's common sense
that's all you're doing you know you're
revolting at some poor kid who you
assaulted with a bike lock this isn't a
socialist revolution this is nonsense
you know it's you larping you wish i
mean this is the thing they go well
we're out in the streets doing stuff and
say yeah but the people who used to do
that actually had problems you are well
a champagne socialist you you're you're
on what fifty thousand dollars a year if
not more you know you're not deprived
you're not you know you're not even
working for other people your problem is
you hate the rich and your problem is
you've got a guilty conscience because
you're not one of the poor that's your
problem so go and [ __ ] deal with it
don't go around hitting other people
because of it honestly these people piss
me off yeah they're i mean it really
it's disgusting what you're doing and do
you know what piss me off though is when
liberals say oh i'm okay with socialism
no you're not if you're okay with
socialism you're not a liberal or you
don't understand socialism you know i
mean there are like non-marxist
conceptions of socialism but you won't
be able to find any of them now yeah
it's all marxian theology of theology
seems a bit cool but
you have to be opposed to that and if
you're not opposed to that you're not a
liberal you don't know what you're
talking about my guest which we're
airing tomorrow but we taped yesterday
was uh peter bogosian who you might know
who's uh i know the name he's a
philosophy professor up at portland
state university really great guy uh
he's a little bit uh he doesn't have a
beard no i'm thinking of another guy i
didn't quite have known him he had quite
wavy hair and a nice beard and
philosophically professor with a beard
you were making a
fairy he was on your show yeah he's been
on my show yeah no there was no i'll
find the name another uh well peter
called it a secular religion which is
why so you're you're calling it a
theology it really it's becoming as
radicalized as a religion yeah with
firstborn with first in and all that it
shares a lot of the same um properties
that's why it's it's all-encompassing
it's a complete world view and the whole
world view has to be in place for it to
be working you can't i mean like with
with class with with liberalism it's i
mean you like i mean haig made this
point really really clear in the road
certainly i'm sorry you're thinking
about brett weinstein i think from
evergreen state that no no no no that's
that's a different chapter but anyway
but hey make this point really clear
look
you can afford some social programs you
know that's an acceptable thing to do as
long as they're universal as long as
they adhere to the principles of
individualism
but you can't do that in a system that
is all-encompassing and i don't want to
say the word totalitarian
but i can't think of a better way of
describing it requires the totality of
all of your beliefs to fall in line so
this is why these people seem like
cookie cutters whereas when you go to
someone who considers themselves to come
out of this sort of english liberal
tradition they've often got very
different opinions on very on certain
subjects and align on the the sort of
core beliefs
um but these people don't you know they
they they have very and they they say oh
we disagree and then okay on what point
do you disagree and it's it's some tiny
fringe disagreement at the very margins
of the ideology but almost everything
else is complete and it's like it's
almost a religion you know it's so
interesting you talk about the cookie
cutter mentality and we know that they
love purging people with original
thoughts and getting rid of all their
real individuals and they love diversity
but not diversity of thought and even as
you were saying that i was thinking for
all the videos that i've watched of
yours and for as well as i think i know
what you think
off the top of my head i don't know if
you're even pro-choice or what you think
about the death penalty exactly which is
kind of interesting and you can probably
differently so i'm i'm pro-choice
begrudgingly i think it's a horrible
choice but i think ultimately
it's a necessary evil it's a necessary
evil and i'm against the death penalty i
am as well because it doesn't work but i
think you can make strong logical
arguments against both of those you
absolutely i mean like a counter
argument would be well why should we
have someone who has been convicted and
we can be sure of the evidence why
should we hold them at taxpayer expense
what's the point you know what do we
want to run the risk of them actually
leaving jail after brutally murdering
some children or something
like it's hard to argue against that you
know you then have to make a sort of
moral humanist argument say well
is it right to ever actually take a life
you know what if what if we're wrong you
know there's always there's always got
to be that room for down there's always
got to be the room to say well you know
some tomorrow some evidence might come
up that they're actually innocent we
were completely wrong for whatever
reason and so we should we should always
keep that as an option open but i mean a
pragmatist could say yeah well if
chances are you know so isn't that the
beauty though of really caring about a
political philosophy or any philosophy
more than a party or more than a
politician or any of that in that
whatever your answer had been there i
think you could have made as strong
classical liberal or liberal arguments
as i could have made the other way we
happen to agree on both of those things
but i'm sure we can find something that
we do yeah of course but i think i think
the important thing is the
it's like the platform on which to
discuss it it's not
it it doesn't require everyone to agree
on everything whereas i mean this is why
these sort of like totalitarian
ideologies they have to purge the wrong
thinkers because and it's liberalism has
got quite a narrow focus as his base you
know it's
universal rights you know the idea of
freedom of man the brotherhood of man
all that sort of thing
it's quite a narrow column that most
people will agree with i mean not many
people will turn around so you know what
i actually think we should have an
aristocracy you know
i actually think that maybe maybe some
people shouldn't have the same rights as
white people or something like that it's
it's very hard to find someone like that
and so it's easy for
most people to agree with this court and
then branch off into various strains
whereas with the
socialism is effectively the reverse
yeah you know it's very very very
demanding that you believe all of these
things because all of these ideas prop
one another up you know you if you if
you take out one like you know core
piece of it then it affects all of these
other ones that are effectively holding
the whole thing together
and yeah i mean this is why that when
someone starts saying well actually i'm
not sure about this like purge the wrong
thinker i mean you see it happening with
lacy green and the social justice
warriors now it's terrifying yeah you
know i mean i like to think that if
tomorrow i turned around and said you
know what i think i might actually be a
conservative i think i might actually
think that we should live in is what is
essentially a christian controlled
society because obviously secularism is
another pillar of it i mean at least i
think i would be able to have the
conversation with people
you know
but i mean maybe maybe i'd be thrown out
of the club who knows yeah i get thrown
out of a lot of clubs
for wrong things i i like your metaphor
there because i almost see it as it's
like liberalism at its roots is sort of
a giant pot with a lot of fertile ground
and because of that you're going to grow
out a lot of different ideas and sort of
competing ideas that hopefully hopefully
the best ones will rise to the top and
all that where progressivism
is actually a very small pot so you
don't have room to to grow out a lot of
competing ideas because they gotta they
gotta pull you out like a weed it'll
break the pot yeah you know the pot will
crack when the the roots start coming
out of it and so yeah they have to
regularly weed themselves out you know
weed out the wrong thinkers or the wrong
growers or whatever yeah fit it into the
metaphor so i know we could do we could
literally do five hours of just
definitions and all of em
one thing
on the subject of definitions there is
one important thing right yeah um
practically all of these ideologies
think that they're advocating for
freedom that's the that's the
fundamental principle i mean if you you
can go back and and read um
any of the sort of social because a
hundred years ago all of the why it's no
different to now i suppose all of the
sort of um prominent intellectuals that
we generally think well of now we're
socialists they consider themselves
socialist
i mean you go like bertrand russell or
oscar wilde or something like that they
they wrote good socialist literature and
if you go back and read it now i mean
i mean bertrand russell wrote a book
called proposed rose to freedom that the
purpose of socialism in their minds is
freedom the problem is it relies on
it relies on their being in excess of
wealth and unfortunately social
socialism doesn't produce an excess of
wealth it's we're not in a position
where we're going to end up with a
classless stateless society it's not
going to happen i mean what
what they think is that so it might
happen but it's going to be after some
great war
it won't be after a great war that'll
actually set the clock back what will
happen is when we've finally mechanized
practically everything in the world when
man no longer has to labor then we will
have socialism
until then it's not going to happen
because one man is making things with
the fruit of his own hands he needs to
be able to own the product of his own
labor because and this this comes back
to lock's principle of self-ownership if
you don't own yourself someone else does
and this is why private property is
important and it private property will
only go away when there's no value in
owning private property and there'll
only be no value in owning private
property when there is no scarcity and
when there is no scarcity it won't
matter it just simply won't matter no
one will even think about private
property because no one will work yeah
and that's the only time that socialism
is ever going to work and we're nowhere
near it so they should shut up and go
home so i think what you're saying is
that the socialists should all be about
robots taking over and everything
because yeah they should yeah i mean
they're probably a very scary thought
i don't think it sounds terrifying to be
honest i mean
i don't see any problem with like state
ownership of
the means of production in principle the
the problem is the
necessary requirement take away private
ownership from everyone else
i mean i i don't mind if if like
tomorrow the government wanted to open
up a giant robotics factory where you
could go down and you could and it would
literally just be a huge assembly line
of robots producing i mean you had a
screen you press i want a new car or
something you pay however much the car
costs and then however long it takes to
build and then you've got the car made
from the state it could well be a lot
cheaper i don't mind that at all you
know there's nothing inherently
anti-individualistic about it well
wouldn't that eliminate competition
which is which is not necessarily
because i mean it might be that people
create things that
can't be created by this
you know by this automated process or
whatever
but the fact that they then as well need
to take away your ability to own your
own means of production that's the
problem that's when the oppression comes
in and because eventually you end up
losing the ownership of your own labor
you're in an ownership of yourself it's
an interesting concession you're making
this in and of itself you're not against
this
it's what the repercussions yeah exactly
it's it's what it's what comes along
with it in and of itself it doesn't
infringe my rights at all you know it's
it's not a problem in fact i get cheaper
i get some sort of cheaper product out
of it probably so it's not necessarily a
problem but it's everything that comes
with it that i can't i just i have to
object to because ultimately i think
hayek was right when he said this will
lead to a new serfdom and if you look at
any communist re well i say communists
but they were actually socialist regimes
state socialist regimes
they i mean they would force you to work
you didn't have the option like for
example like my wife is a housewife she
doesn't have to work
that wouldn't be acceptable in a
socialist regime everyone has to work
but thankfully thanks to capitalism we
don't have to you know because i earned
the means of my own production and i'm
successful enough that i can actually
make my wife a lady of leisure to look
after my children yeah that's like a
good patriarch
but that's actually a great segue to
where i wanted to go with this which is
that so i think we've shown for the
people that don't know you you're the
command of the issues you know you know
i i do you know what you're
what's interesting is so you're in this
youtube community that i'm obviously in
as well and you've met we just talked
briefly before we sat down but you
mentioned something interesting about
how it's like for us that for those of
us that have been talking about this
stuff whether you agree with this or not
but those of us that have been talking
about politics on youtube in our sort of
circles that we're doing it they're
constantly expanding and changing and
all that yeah that we're refining our
ideas oh and i i love this concept
because it seems to me that internet
culture is bubbling out now into
mainstream culture and now there's this
group of people online that i think
we're a part of that have helped refine
some ideas so that people that are not
part of it can take those ideas and
hopefully
run for office or put those
or just put them into their own lives
however they do and absolutely i mean
like um
i want to give full credit to all of the
people in all of the ideological spheres
that i oppose yeah and opposed to me
yeah they are absolutely intellectual
prize fighters they are
100
oh i mean i i don't want to say experts
that's a bit too far but they are very
very well versed in their ideological
sphere you know the libertarians the
socialists the anarchists all of these
people are and the even the alt-right
many of them are really well read in
their particular narrow genre and they
they are very
comprehensively read sometimes and they
put forth their arguments very very well
and it is like a brawl down on the uh
down the shop floor is aware yeah um and
if it wasn't for them and if we make
each other sharper there's no doubt
about it and so there's definitely
definitely a lot to be said for the
grand argument that's going on on
youtube um but yeah the
there's um
there's a term called the the long march
through the institutions that uh the old
rights will tell you the marxists have
done through universities and it's hard
to really argue with this i mean whether
it was a coordinated thing or not it's
obviously of debate but it's hard to
argue that they've done this because
they literally are almost in command of
these universities and like what was the
brett weinstein's university evergreen
state that was it um yeah
they've taken over absolutely as i
mentioned as i mentioned to tim poole
earlier it's like if this if this
ideology of this post-modern left them
leftism sjw thing if it really worked
shouldn't that university which was the
most arguably the most leftist campus in
america brett weinstein a far left as he
described himself a deeply progressive
person who i now know and like very much
by the way oh i'm choosing a lovely guy
that shouldn't that place have been the
most harmonious
ideologically pure wonderful
uh shangri-la of leftism and instead
it's an intolerant psychotic
bin of lunacy and i love that it all
comes from him saying i'm not going to
let you discriminate against me on the
basis of my race and fair you know
hands down applaud the guy for standing
up for himself because when you have a
mob of ideologically convicted bullies
you know and these people will commit
violence i mean we've seen it so many
times they will start the violence for
him to then stand up to them in the
flesh you know when they're bearing down
on him saying look i want a dialect i
cannot debate that's incredibly brave i
mean honestly i don't i mean a lot of
people i can see why a lot of people
just
lower their heads and carry on their
lives because it's a lot easier if you
do but that's the point that's the
reason they win is because of this we
need people who do not agree with them
to say they don't agree with them and
this this is why i'm saying that this is
what actually needs to happen is we need
to begin
our long march through the institutions
if you're in university at the moment
and you're
concerned with the
progression of marxist ideologies and
you're a liberal and you want to promote
these values you have to stay in the
university i know you might be thinking
well i'm doing my degree and whatever
i'm going to get out i'm going to make a
lot of money
well that's you actually abdicating your
responsibility to the next generation i
hate to say it it's so interesting
you're going to have to stay there yeah
when i when i go to college campuses
they ask me that a lot i'll get at the q
a at the end there'll be kids that'll go
you know i see all this stuff my
professor doesn't want me to say this
gender pronoun or doesn't believe in
gender at all or just some other crazy
nonsense and they'll say but you know
what i got to get out of here with a
degree and i always say look i don't
envy your position and i don't begrudge
you whatever you have to do in your own
personal life absolutely to
graduate and hopefully be a productive
member of society but the problem is
once they get you bowing
that hand will only get stronger
i mean
that i think that's slightly different
what i meant i mean like if you're a
student and you're doing a degree don't
be a hero you know get your degree you
you're okay so we're talking about two
different sets yeah
get your degree and and if you you can't
stand to be in there get out but if
you're concerned about the progress of
this ideology
and you're thinking well you know if
you've finished like a phd or whatever
you think well i could become a
professor or i could enter the private
uh private market and and earn lots of
money
well you've got the choice is is earning
lots of money more important to you than
the intellectual tradition you're going
to bequeath to your students if you were
to become a professor you know and
there's a lot there's a lot of people
who talk down
about people who teach and i mean
there's you know those who do can those
who don't teach and i i find that i mean
i it's sad really because it
disincentivizes people because there's
nothing wrong with spreading good ideas
you know ideas that are genuinely not
bigoted and do not result in bigotry and
these people whose ideas do result in
bigotry have taken over the shop you've
got to do something about it and it's up
to you you know it's it that no one else
is going to do it if it's not you who
and if not now when yeah you know how
much how much more are you going to let
this carry on if and honestly i mean
this to anyone watching if you're in the
university and you think you've got the
the smarts to get to the top do it stay
there do it write some books you can
still get rich write some books become
successful
you've got to stand your ground you know
and that means taking a position and
advancing yourself against the hate mob
how much stronger do you think the ideas
that we're talking about are now than
they were three years ago even just the
phrase classical liberalism which
was never thrown around in america only
two years ago now i hear it all the time
oh in the sphere of public debate
they're getting thrashed absolutely
thrashed i mean like
for example all the universities like
mizzou missouri university um they're
they've had to start cutting programs
the the market is killing them off as it
should you know i can't imagine what's
gonna happen to evergreen in the next
round of enrollments yeah but i imagine
the market's going to take its toll on
them too and it's a state school where
they have all first off they didn't even
hit from what i understand they didn't
even hit their the numbers of enrollees
that they had to last year to get oh
really i can't swear to that hundred no
no that's what someone told me um but
that either way they have such chaos
there right now there's many strong
arguments you could make for cutting
funding all together good the faculty
didn't the administration didn't back
the faculty and now they have the the
inmates running the assets absolutely i
i mean this this difference to the
students is baffling to me you know i
i i
can't i mean when i went to university i
would never have imagined such a thing
would happen but that was like almost
well about 15 years ago now so
computer science and i hated it i hated
every second of it i didn't want to do
it and i only did it because i could use
computers and it was it was easy to me
so i just but it was tremendously boring
and i dropped out in the second year
yeah because i hated it i i'd never even
considered doing like philosophy or
political science or anything because i
come from
well
my parents come from a working-class
background and they worked up to the
middle class and they they were like you
get something vocational you know and
you know computer science seemed
vocational but it was just tremendously
boring and i wish i'd never i wish i'd
gone for something in the liberal arts
to be honest it was much much more
myself well i guess it worked it worked
you're making some sense you're doing
liberal arts in real life now i am yeah
i i might actually um i might actually
go back to university just to get the
degree just to shut people up to say oh
you don't have a degree in this well no
i don't yeah but you know look at the
people who do have degrees on this now
yeah some of them aren't the best no
some of them know and then some of the
degrees make no sense and then they
wonder why they can't get jobs yeah
let's talk a little bit about internet
culture because yeah because that's the
other piece of this that i think yeah i
think most of our audiences really
understand yeah but a lot of it gets
lost in the translation when it bubbles
up to mainstream and uh so
for me for example i do a bit of
trolling online not not directly but i
mean i fight a little bit online when
it's necessary when this thing happened
to me with mother jones i went on an
absolute assault that's not trolling but
occasionally i'll you know fight with
this person because it's it's how you
make the conversation happen but i try
to keep it sort of within a certain
boundary of whatever you you definitely
have dove in to the troll world the pepe
the memes all of that stuff
i i have literally never seen you once
tweet something that i thought was truly
offensive or and certainly not bigoted
or any of that stuff you're you're using
the very tools they've used against us
on them in effect and i think it's
pretty great um well this this this is
the great thing about the internet um
the the internet is hilarious but the
problem is that many
[Music]
the problem i think is pretensions
because a lot of people tend to hold
especially well educated people hold a
lot of pretensions around themselves and
i always find this baffling because like
well if you're accomplished and you're
intellectual and you've achieved all of
these things why do you need to be
pretentious
why do you need to suggest that oh oh
someone has said something i don't like
and therefore i will never talk to that
person so what if they did so what if
they did yeah it doesn't take away or or
then they retweet it to show what a
victim they are which is
when i retweet them it's like to mock
these idiots yeah exactly but this is
about your ego yeah this this is about
your ego and honestly i mean this this
is essentially russo's conception of the
bourgeoisie this is about wanting to be
seen and wanting to have status and it
and i i hate the bourgeoisie
they're so pretentious and what i find
hilarious is when they like these these
bourgeois socialists will turn around
and say oh well i'm doing it for the
people for the working class it's like
you hate the working class because
they're the trolls on twitter you can't
stand you know don't even talk to me
about doing anything for the working
class yeah do not even pretend but one
thing one thing that um
that people forget is that
it's the definition of the term trolling
because when the internet was new when i
was logging on a 28k modem when i was
like 16 or something i know yeah i've
been doing was it in color at that time
but um the whole the whole definition of
trolling it wasn't
the definition has been changed by
social justif justice activists to mean
sending someone a threat or hate or
something like that that's not trolling
that's just abuse and you shouldn't do
that because it's a wrong to do it b
it's totally unproductive and it creates
the victim narrative that they're
looking for yeah because they can use
the victim narrative as a form of
currency in order to buy sympathy from
other people and buy favors from them
whereas the person sending that will
only be ever seen as a villain don't do
it you gain you i mean you know i'd like
to appeal on a moral level and say look
it's wrong to do it you know how do they
feel normally but that doesn't change
people's minds so think of it from your
own personal self-interest you don't
gain anything from doing it yeah they
believe victimhood is virtue and you're
giving them virtue on a silver platter
exactly that's precisely you are
actually setting them up to succeed and
you're setting yourself up to fail
but that's not what trolling actually is
and at least it wasn't in the early days
of the internet trolling someone was
basically putting out bait
giving them enough rope with which to
hang themselves and let them to get let
themselves get worked up over
not really anything you know that was
the thing that was the trick i mean like
um
the the best example i can think of
actually is um
it happened to me today i i
i think it was yesterday i tweeted out
look if trolling is an art and that was
always the phrase that went with it
trolling is an art it's it's it's
basically like intellectual satire you
know and uh trolling is an art if you
don't
if you don't uh understand that you
don't understand trolling and then
someone tweeted at me saying trolling is
a art
as in he left off the a yeah yeah
any grammar nazis he's gonna jump on
that and that's the point that's the
bait yeah you know it's not offensive
it's not insulting it's about testing
your capacity to divine the meaning from
what is being said and if you can't draw
out the meaning from it then that person
can have a laugh at your expense because
you just got it wrong it's so
interesting i don't know that i've ever
thought of it so cleanly actually for as
much as i know about this but you know
my i enjoy the trolls for the most part
like the good especially the ones that
are being the financial trolls right the
trolls now there's the other group who
are just the evil people who are just
writing go [ __ ] yourself all day long
and horrible so i have no problem at
this point muting and blocking those
people it's like
you're you're just adding nothing but
evil the truth they're
spleen that's what they're doing they're
angry for some reason they just want to
let off some steam yeah and okay well
fine but i don't i don't need to read it
or listen to it but i don't it doesn't
come right i don't stop them from doing
it but the trolls there are times where
i'll tweet signing and someone will turn
it on me or mock something i did and i'm
like man that that i wish i was thought
of that yeah that was good and i've even
when i've done public events i've talked
to them about pepe and harambe and all
that and i'll be like i know you all or
have secret accounts and i can see it in
everyone's face they all have their
secret pepe accounts and all that stuff
but pepe is probably the best example of
this right of something that
meant nothing
yeah then anything and yet affected the
presidential election in america well
yeah i mean like it meant anything is it
better yeah that's that's the thing
the great thing about pepe is um
pepe the green frog for people who don't
yeah yeah imagine anyone watching this
doesn't know
the great thing is um
it's almost like the life cycle of the
meme where it starts with um i i think i
i
i don't wanna i don't describe this
inaccurately but it's hard to describe
it with any accuracy
if you look at the earliest ones it's
all pepe looking sad and dejected and on
the outside of anything that's going on
you know he's and it was the sad frog
meme feels bad man and now if you look
at it it's all the sort of like staring
at you knowingly with a little smile
yeah it's the i don't give a damn about
your conceits meme you know and this can
be applied to anything i mean you'll
find you know for every pepe of adolf
hitler you find you'll find a pepe of a
you know a jewish pepe or you know
you know whatever it's anything and it
can be applied to anything you know
which is why when do you have that ultra
rare pepe that's made out of oh
say anything somebody sent me one of
those i'm very excited yeah because
someone will want it and i'm not giving
it away
because it's so stupid it is it's just
stupidity and yeah and so when like uh
what was the name hillary clinton yeah
is complaining about a green frog meme
to the entire world which was is that
the ultimate trolling of all yes they
got hillary clinton to address this so
at the time at the same time while her
campaign is colluding with the dnc to
destroy bernie yes
she literally made the pepes and the
harambees and she legitimized them she
legitimized them so she legitimized the
movement that she's so that she
apparently hated or was this hate
movement
while at the same time colluding to
destroy the other guy that he's running
for it's just absolutely ridiculous um
you know
the the problem the problem is it's
entirely satirical you know everything
is
it's entirely ironic it's entirely
satirical free kakistan um
that's the point it's it's not something
you can rebut you know the point is to
get you to bite yeah and hillary bit and
it's like hillary all you can do with p
when someone's mocking you all you can
do is go fair enough and ignore it
that's all you can do there is no other
saving grace you can't argue against
them you can't give them what they want
which is attention and this again it
comes back to the very earliest days of
the internet don't feed the trolls
that's the only way to beat a troll
they're looking for you to bite and if
you bite then they'll reel you in if you
ignore them they'll go and search
somewhere else for a bite do you think
it really shows how patently out of
touch she was and the campaign that she
obviously had no idea what pepe was but
someone from the campaign you know the
focus group was like we've been thinking
about this hillary and we need to really
put an l in the coffin of these people
and what we're going to do is we're
going to talk about pepe and then she
just went up you know and then she went
up there with a prepared speech and
talked about it and it just showed it
just showed the archaic
machinery of drivel that that these
campaigns have become well i think i
actually i think it's they just don't
understand the internet because i mean
they're older you know these people are
older they're they're what we would call
it
trump's campaign did get it though
because they did they did things that
were much more effective in that yeah
well where else was trump going to get
support from wasn't going to get it from
the msn was he yeah you know but
retweeting a pepe of him uh
you know on the podium genius right all
right genius let's talk about kekkistan
because you mentioned kekistan i am a
supporter of kakistan and the kakistani
people i think they deserve freedom they
deserve their own land i think they're
good people who have been unfairly
maligned
uh i i am a great supporter of theirs
anything that i can do for the people of
pakistan who i'm sure are commenting
right this very second
on this video um tell me about the the
good people in pakistan and their desire
and uh need and
just
uh cause yeah so kakistan um
to be blunt is a parody of identity
politics um and this i don't i mean
anyone who's familiar with everything i
just said that was just from a parody
i'm i'm afraid so
if you didn't know now i hate to break
it all right um but yeah it's a parody
of identity politics because all of all
of these um groups and it's not just on
the left it's always also on the right
the alt-right are an identitarian
movement classical liberalism is not an
identitarian movement and it's hard to
fight against identity politics
especially when the premise that the
left comes with is that white people
cannot have an identity and i mean i
don't want to see white identitarianism
rise you know i don't like
identitarianism of any stripe you know
and i don't want to see white people
suddenly saying well because we're white
we get x because you're not white you
get why you know like in this just the
reverse of the social justice was going
well because you're not white you get x
and because you're white you get why i
don't want that at all you know that's
that's not equality to me that's that's
in fact the antithesis that's again
creating a new form of aristocracy so
i'm completely against the idea
and it's hard to fight
unless you satirize it and suddenly if
you've got an identity called say a
kekkazani who's an oppressed [ __ ] poster
on the internet who's always getting
banned from twitter or you know blocked
from comment sections and this this now
that's a form of oppression and how is
it not oppression what did you do i
posted a joke well we're going to censor
you for that joke well now i am actually
being oppressed this is i mean it's
something wrong it's a very
a very mild form of oppression it's not
it's but it's high-level controlling
yeah it is high levels it's very
technically oppression and so now i have
a victim identity now i am a victimized
class now i deserve to buy into all of
your identity policies and the best
thing about it is that every
identitarian movement hates it yeah i
mean obviously the social justice
warriors think it's it's racist neo-nazi
stuff right but the funny thing is when
richard spencer tweeted out hashtag free
kakistan his followers went nuts against
him they were like no oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah they were just i mean just like no
no this is cancer you can't do this take
this back delete this you have to stop
this perfect what was the reasoning
there because his followers understood
it more than him like his followers
understood oh i think they i think they
completely understand that it undermines
identity politics because that's the
point of it yeah it's it's
do you think he if he was sitting here
with us do you think he would admit that
he's playing identity politics oh yeah
absolutely i think he's well aware that
he's creating a i mean
i've seen like um you know short
interviews with him he's saying he wants
a white identity movement in order to
compete with um
the the left and
i i don't want any identitarian
movements i'm tired of them i think they
all need to basically be um
be expunged i no i'm i'm sorry you
saying i'm white therefore i'm black
therefore i'm gay therefore i'm trans
therefore it it's not an argument
basically right yeah but it's just not
an argument so you're saying you just
want to be judged on the things that you
think you know is that what you're
telling me that you don't want to be
judged as a bearded person or i believe
there was a famous racist who said
judge a man on the content of his
character and not the color of his skin
and i mean that guy's a tremendous
racist and should be
should be fully fully exposed for the of
the years but i'm afraid i do agree with
that point that one point everyone makes
everyone makes one group exactly uh all
right all right we got about 15 minutes
left before the before the q a so let's
just knock out some political things uh
kind of quickly give me your basic
feelings on trump because i've seen some
people say well sargon not he's not
attacking trump enough and i people
criticize me you're not attacking trump
enough as if there aren't enough outlets
too well that's exactly my feeling on it
i mean you know
i don't
really like
trump's politics and i never have but
the thing is
it
it must be obvious to everyone that
there is a great deal of pressure built
up at the bottom of our societies as in
the poorest the least able to actively
defend themselves in the public sphere
are being actively marginalized by the
left the left intelligentsia the
academics the liberal elites then the
media these people have been and i'm
going to use the term and i mean it
literally oppressing the sort of you
know white
middle america like you know the lower
class middle sort of i don't know
whatever you call the center of america
these days i don't i'm not from america
i don't know the middle yeah um they fly
over states yeah there's no it's no
surprise that it it's the coastal elites
that are in the blue and the the center
that's in the red and it's very much the
same in britain i mean not with trump
obviously but with brexit it was a
revolt by the english working class
against the english british elite class
who would just do exactly the same as
they do in america and call them racists
how dare you advocate for your own
interests that's a racist thing to do
and they're only doing that because
their own interests aren't threatened
either that's the thing if if we were
bringing not yet anyway yeah exactly not
yet but if we were bringing over
millions of liberal journalists from
other countries that would be the first
people complaining they'd be saying what
do you mean i can't get in i can't get a
job writing at the guardian because
they've hired a dozen people who barely
speak english from a foreign country i'm
i we need to cut down immigration but
because they're not being threatened by
it and they're not affected by it
because they're in the gated community
somewhere else that they give a damn
they're not seeing their salaries go
down they're not seeing themselves
impoverished they don't care it's the
most selfish goddamn thing in the world
you know you're so right i'll just give
you one quick personal example on this
yeah uh that a couple months ago um
i saw uh ben shapiro who you probably
know got into a little a little fight
with this guy jonathan chait who i think
is at new york magazine who's a big
lefty and they were fighting about small
business and chait said something like
small business isn't even a real thing
it's just what the
the media uses to keep you quiet you
know some some nonsensical thing and i
responded to him and i don't even follow
this guy but i saw the thing and i was
like that's insane because i have a
small business i'm a small business i
have a small business i am extremely
proud of the employees that i have who
by the way i pay all of the yeah all the
health insurance and all that we now
have a part-timer and all that i built a
studio and a small business that i'm
very proud of so i wrote back to him and
i said i'm very proud of the small
business i've created i've created
several jobs i'm very proud of that and
he retweeted me and wrote oh something's
the effect of oh you've created several
jobs implying that
that creating several jobs is somehow an
embarrassment or that i shouldn't i'm
not enough or i'm not an authority but
the irony being if i had created a
hundred jobs he'd say i'm an evil
corporate model so what is the number
what are we talking about is 26 26 am i
now
an idiot who doesn't know what he's
talking about or am i an evil corporate
model well that's just that's just the
most ridiculous thing i've ever heard i
mean
small businesses are ideally what would
be i mean that they it would be better
for us to have more small businesses all
small businesses yeah i would be all for
that i would much prefer it if and i i
don't want to see corporations broken up
using government authority or anything
like that but if somehow we end up in a
future where most people are either
small business owners or employees of
small businesses that in my opinion
would be better for everyone yeah you
know so
when you say that that's partly because
of it's not only because of your
political people but it's because of
your your literal existence you as you
just said you are a small businessman
you work for yourself there's a great
sense of pride there's a sense of
ownership and the thing is i mean i i
commission people to do things you know
i commission art or commission yeah you
know i i like running competitions where
i can offer quite a substantial price
for a piece of art or something you know
and i like being able to you know give
back i like being able to do things for
people
that involve you know helping them
progress in their career as well you
know as as a voluntary transaction you
know and i think that's a fantastic
thing and that it and what annoys me
about all of this right is that is what
i would define as empowerment you know a
person
just literally building something with
their own you know two hands
metaphorically and putting something
together like this you know you now have
employees and the the closer you are to
the power then the more the power is
responsive to you that's just a general
rule of power politics and it applies to
anything ever you know which is why
like a giant corporation
the the ceos of this corporation are
probably not even in the same country as
most of their employees yeah and so
they're not going to respond to any of
the employee demands they're not going
to treat their employees fairly they're
not well i mean
there's a chance that they're not going
to and not through malice either but
just through ignorance whereas you work
with your employees every day you're
very close to them you're friends with
them you like your employees you weren't
married to my executive producer that's
you want them to do well you know
there's there's definitely a strong
argument for that just for the
betterment of people's lives the actual
life they're living the the personal
wealth the happiness and their job i
definitely think small businesses are
much better for them giant soulless
corporations yeah and and therein lies
the rub i have too few employees
i have too many but the fact that he
retweets you saying oh look at this oh
good god yeah uh all right wait i want
to dive a little more into brexit
because we did not in america there was
not a great understanding of what was
going on there was basically there's no
impression either yeah
that's funny i mean there was in effect
we had no coverage of it until about two
days before then the day before there
was a ton of coverage the day after
everyone was going crazy like oh my god
what happened sort of like the day after
trump yeah and now there's no discussion
of it again um
breakdown breaks it a little bit though
so i i understand what you're saying
about the working class versus the
elites it has now also in effect led to
corbin which is which is a little
bizarre
so just give me a couple of times yeah
okay so the the quick breakdown is um
the british public has never really
liked the european union and i put this
down my opinion
is because the european union is heavily
dominated by the germans financially and
philosophically you know and the british
have always been very standoffish about
the european union because they don't
like the idea and the european union
started as an economic community where
people would cooperate and it has slowly
but surely over the decades been
coalescing into a federalized sovereign
nation state and it's been trying to get
all of these trappings i mean in 2011
the british vetoed a motion for them to
get their own army and this is
particularly dangerous because they
don't raise taxes from anyone they raise
taxes from the government they collect a
portion of the taxes raised from
governments and but they don't raise
them directly themselves so they're not
they're not accountable to any of the
demos in europe
and i don't know why most of europe is
acceptable of this but that's
continental europe for you the british
are not happy with this and they demand
accountability from the politicians they
always have
and the the sort of english liberalism
that britain's always projected has
always required this and so when people
and again it comes down to the whole
philosophy behind liberalism
it's about being a peer i mean we have
no po respect for our politicians
corbyn's cult of personality is a
bizarre thing to watch because i mean
you know it's very middle-class thing to
watch as well um but for most of the
working class most just
people who aren't part of that group
they don't like corbin corbin was the
most well no tony blair was the most
disliked politician in the country then
it was jeremy corbyn yeah i mean you
know this time six months ago when or
like a year ago when brexit happened
our current prime minister theresa may
she was phenomenally popular
and it was and jeremy corbyn was the
most unpopular how do you get there then
how do you get from a principle like
brexit to me strikes me as an
individualistic principle we want to
control
our destiny again how do you get from
that to six months later having the
collectivist ideology of corbyn oh
is this completely may is it completely
on may it's on six months in may uh yeah
actually it's it's really hard not to
put it on theresa may um
she came out with a tremendously bad
manifesto she refused to debate she
didn't stand for anything she didn't
come out in the public sense she didn't
attack corbyn's ideology which she
should have done from the word so easy i
know she should have just put you out
there she she could have just put up a
picture of corbin giving chavez a hug
with the quote underneath fidel castro
was a hero of social justice which is an
actual quote from jeremy corbyn jesus i
i swear to god the man is a lunatic he
is he's he's a soft totalitarian and
people because he hides it behind this
facade of being softly spoken and oh but
i really care it's like okay but you
didn't care when your momentum supports
which is hard left support in the left
um were putting bricks through the rebel
labor mp's windows they didn't care then
you know he is a dangerous man and
nobody wants to see it because they like
a little bit of violence oh they love it
they think it's completely justified
they've got no problem with it because
your morality is based by your
ideological framework if you think the
evil capitalists are oppressing the
working class then you are totally
justified in violence towards the evil
capitalists and anyone who supports
their regime so all of a sudden i mean
you know they become enemies of the
people and that is that that's one thing
that liberalism can't do it can't
otherwise someone into a category that
is not acceptable you know you can't
because it's a universal philosophy it's
for everyone literally every single
individual regardless of opinion
regardless of status
should enjoy the same rights and a
violation of any of those rights is a
problem which is why i'm often forced to
defend donald trump or richard spencer
or someone like that people who i never
like and never get along with but i'm
afraid i can't tolerate the left
treating them the way they do it's
unacceptable so my final question for
now then we're going to jump you know
what i think maybe we're going to do a
drink during the q a you want to drink i
would love it what do you drink i feel
like you're like maybe like a scotch or
a whistle
let me see what we can do over there
we've got a lot of stuff behind it but i
think we can do a little something um
all right so we're gonna do the second
half of this q a from the audience on
that um but just to wrap this up um
so i sense you feel you feel optimistic
about this i sense i sense optimism
well i'm not very optimistic about
brexit
but i mean just the general ideas that
we're talking about that they are
starting to yeah i think i think i think
um
what i think we need is for the center
to develop its own political identity
for the center and not not like um
not to say right okay we're you know
white or whatever not identity politics
but to have a conception of itself away
from the extremes of either side because
this this is the problem i mean like
you've got the hard left which are the
anti-far commies and throwing bricks
through windows and beating people with
bike chains and then you've got the
alt-right who are the legitimate racists
who want to you know do whatever racist
things they want to do
and if you're on the right you get kind
of drawn towards that just by
association if you're on the left you
get drawn to that by association if
you're in the center like we are yeah
you've got nothing whereas i think most
people are probably a lot closer to the
center
so what we need to do is find some sort
of like woke centrist
meme where we can say you know what [ __ ]
the extremes [ __ ] them they're both
wrong they're both crazy they're both
dangerous they both don't want dialogue
with the other side whereas in the
center if you're center left your center
right i mean i'm sure that a lot of
people watching on the internet right
now are well aware that people on the
center left and center are having a lot
better conversations about politics than
anyone from the extremes [ __ ] the
extremes they're a tiny fringe of idiots
we need to just ignore them they can
just be safely no you're an idiot
socialist you're an idiot all writer not
interested in your opinions because
you're frankly batty and you require
everything i mean you require radical
comprehensive change the system that
nobody wants to see yeah i know you
don't do the live sit downs that often
but you know how to end an hour that's a
beautiful blending right there all right
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
take one minute we did two minutes last
time we're gonna take one minute i'm
gonna pour carl a drink and then we're
gonna do a q a on on super chat and
patreon 60 seconds set your watches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right all right we're back
i know that took a little more than 60
seconds it was it was ambitious of me we
had to we had to pour he wanted brandy
we got whiskey we got two whiskeys here
so first off
to doing something in real life yeah i
mean isn't it real life something yeah
it is
definitely different to uh sitting in my
office comfortably
i'm not in my elements
all right well you've got some whiskey
on the rocks and we're jumping in uh
we're doing super chat and patreon
and and here we go i have a few i mean
there's already a bajillion questions
here so you better everything can cap on
twenty dollars carl how are you finding
the us so far oh it's wonderful yeah
i i was expecting uh i believe it was
called camifornia uh
is wonderful everyone's everyone's been
really nice really really nice you know
i mean
i i was i was walking
basically your the way you do things
here is different the way we do things
like in uk and i noticed that your your
um
junctions are terrible uh poorly poorly
conceived frankly what do you want out
of our junctions or i think well i was i
was up on the other day and i pressed
the button and i noticed that everyone
was stopped there was no one moving and
this went on for
longer than i thought i was comfortable
to be honest and uh while i was waiting
there there was a really nice chap i
don't know who he was or anything who um
could tell i was obviously not from the
area yeah and uh he basically said oh
you know look the thing up there go down
we ended up walking on the same path we
just ended up having a chat he's like
hey you know we did we'd legal here and
i was like oh great i'll have to get
some and he was like well you can't
because you need a license but i've got
um uh you know one of the electronic
cigarettes thing with cannabis oil here
have a hit and i'll say oh that's such a
nice thing you know it's like yeah this
is just you know i don't know you i'm
just gonna walk i'm never gonna see you
again you're telling me you come to our
our country here and smoke weed on the
streets i absolutely would yeah all
right no no all right we're gonna spend
some time after the camera
all right uh super chat how do we stop
the regressives is there a solution and
will the solution be final these trolls
new trolls
unfortunately we could never actually
have a final solution in the liberal
system and that's a good thing um
so i don't know why i said unfortunately
but
but um yeah the the the
it's the long march you've you've got to
get wherever these people are taking
over you have to take over because i
mean fundamentally these people are
institutionalists they i mean you've
seen this everywhere everyone who's
familiar with sjws has seen it
everywhere they go they suck up to the
power because and this is something a
lot of people don't think about when
they think about social justice think
about how they define
everything it's in terms of power
and you have to think in that sort of
way so you have to think right do i want
them in control or do i want someone
responsible in control and often that
means that if you're like me and you're
some sort of slacker and you just want i
want to play video games and get stoned
well that's great but you have to do it
on your own time because society needs
you to step up and actually be
responsible and do something with your
life i hate to say it i'm not i'm not
the guy who wants to do it either but
you know yeah but but here we are it
reminds me of uh jason whitlock who i
had on from fox sports one couple days
ago or two weeks ago or so was saying
how these people with hashtag resistance
they think they're resisting something
but they're actually sucking up to the
real power
uh yeah yeah they're the ones calling
the chance yeah uh is there a final
solution for the radical left okay we
got it we got it there's gonna be a lot
of final solution
um on patreon i think we basically
addressed this already but what's the
fundamental difference between classical
liberalism and social liberalism um well
the difference is on points of like
policy um but the the i mean really in
reality i am actually a social liberal
but i i say the word classical liberal
because it differentiates the
intellectual tradition i'm drawing on
you know i i'm i'm very very concerned
with
differentiating liberalism from
progressivism and
liberalism from marxism any anything i
mean any intellectual be able to
obviously they'll be like well of course
why would you need to do this but it's
for the layman you know the average
layman doesn't really understand the
difference i think and if you say i'm a
classical liberal then you are firmly
planting your foot in the
concept of self-ownership markets you
know free market economics all that sort
of thing you're firmly planting the foot
there but i'm i'm more than happy to
take like sort of hayek's interpretation
of of the acceptability of social
programs as long as they don't violate
the principles of individuality which of
individualism which means as long as
they're universal that's fine you know
it's acceptable you this you know we can
bear it it's not going to completely
ruin what we consider to be our freedom
so a few people ask me this uh i get
this ass all the time but we have a
couple on patreon about this so then how
would you define the difference between
classical liberalism and libertarianism
because i get that all the teams people
say david right david they go dave
you're you keep saying classical liberal
but it sounds like you're a libertarian
yeah but you're saying some utility of
the state absolutely
yeah it comes into the difference
between whether you think the state is
valid or not frankly um i
the libertarian movement needs to figure
out whether it can accept the existence
of the state
and there are a huge number of
libertarians who are basically closet
and caps and i mean
the anarcho communists are at least more
realistic in the idea of anarchy that
when you have an anarchy you're not
going to own anything which is true the
anarcho-capitalists are totally
delusional they are not going to own any
property if there is no government
government is there to protect your
property rights you being part of your
own property rights and libertarians
need to understand the government isn't
evil
it's just being
mismanaged at the moment the the state
is valid it's got a definitive place and
we need it and we need to be the ones
controlling it
at the moment we're not
uh sargon what are your thoughts on uh
takia do you think it's relevant in
western societies
well i i believe the chemtrails are
turning the frogs gay yes and that is
that i saw that i think on some popular
uh you know i actually i actually looked
into the uh the study alex jones was
citing he's actually underselling it
it's actually telling them trans
i i swear to god i looked into it was a
i think it was in california actually
where a percentage of the frogs um they
they were starting to exhibit feminine
behaviors on contact with a certain kind
of chemical and 10 percent of them
actually went underwent the full
transition into being female and were
fertile but it i i have a friend who's a
doctor who's like look this this this
only applies to frogs and it's only this
species of frog and it's it's you know
and it wasn't part of a globalist plot
it was corporate
corporate malfeasance obviously right
there was like a grain of truth to it
and it's so you're saying it was the
evolutionary plot not the globalist plot
perhaps and what was the first part of
the first part was about takia uh oh
right he means
takiyah yeah um i need to know more
about it to be honest i the basic
premise oh no i understand the premise
but i yeah well i meant for the for the
good people that don't know oh sorry
the basic premise being that that in
islam there is this law or rule of uh
principle that says you're allowed to
lie to westerners pretty or you're
allowed to lie to the other yeah in an
effort to uh
increase the influence of islam see i
i mean i'm sure that is a
i mean i know that is a thing within
islam but i'm
hesitant to embrace the idea
specifically because
it's going to turn into a very very
convenient way to dismiss muslims by
saying well whatever you've just said is
takiyah what i think is right what you
think is wrong you're a liar and i don't
want to do that because you know that's
not engaging with what they're saying or
refuting them on their own terms
i i i'm with you on that um
why do you speak down to the middle
class i'm american and i fall into the
lower middle class because i'm middle
class by the way i've never been to
college and i love my job building crop
dusters why do you speak down to the
middle class okay maybe i'm missing
something no that's a good point right i
should distinguish between the middle
class and bourgeoisie because uh there
is a difference he's talking about being
financially middle class yeah but the
bourgeoisie is something different it's
a cultural conception uh originally i
think it was coined by russo but at
least defined really well by rousseau um
the bourgeoisie are
a gang of pretentious [ __ ] they are the
worst of people they don't even know
that they're the worst of people they
are self-centered they are
absolutely without any conception of
what is actually good and i know because
so many of my friends are portuguese and
they're actually they are good people
but they don't understand their own
deficiencies because i dropped out of
university and i went straight to the
bottom you know i was
i was poor you know i mean i've spent
times in my life where i've had to
subsist on welfare otherwise i wouldn't
have lived in a house you know i
wouldn't have had food and then i've
worked my way back out of it you know
slowly but steadily but these people
don't they they grow up in you know
comfortable middle class environment
they go to university they get their
degrees they go and do their jobs and
they're not wealthy you know they might
be struggling because their jobs they
might get a degree in something that
doesn't pay very well and so they might
find themselves doing a stint at
starbucks and stuff but they hold a
remarkable amount of um
conceit and pretensions about themselves
and if you
violate these pretensions they despise
you
and that's a problem for me because i
try not to hold pretensions because if
you look at the working class and the
lower classes they don't hold any
potential yeah so you're not called the
middle class per se you're talking about
pretension that comes along a certain
subset of it i'm really talking about
the bourgeoisie
middle class specifically in this
context i think is referring to earnings
nothing wrong with someone mid learning
in fact i want you to earn more you know
and i know that you've if you've gone up
from the lower class to get to the
middle class even if you've come down
you know you've you're going to have
been doing this through your own hard
work and labor and good on you you
should earn more in fact i hope you earn
more i hope you become a millionaire so
self-made millionaire is the dream of
any right-thinking liberal i think yeah
i'll want up you i want you to earn more
and i want the government to take less
so that would be nice there you go uh uh
super chat dave love your show keep it
up sargon i told mundane matt that if
there is one nearby he should take you
out to dinner to five guys burgers
there's one within about two miles from
here by the way for burgers
uh
gigi represent a toast and french fry
for me and did you get kekistan on the
uk census list we haven't had the census
yet i think it's uh 22 2022 i think is
the next census all right um but i tell
you what when that comes around i'm
gonna be making a big noise about that
uh and we're gonna see how many we can
get on there i will be happy to give you
a signal boost on that uh super chat how
can we make centrism sexy you gave a
nice little ending to our first hour
yeah is that i mean i think sanity and
just sort of logic and reason is
starting to have an appeal well i don't
know if it's sexy but there's an appeal
now that maybe there wasn't three years
ago the problem with just saying things
like logic and reason is that there is
logic behind the extremist positions
they're just often very selective in
that logic and so
it it's not just a panacea to to appeal
to people because they will just say
well we're logical as well and
technically they have a logic behind
them um
but i think i think um
the center left and the center right
need to turn around and say hey you know
what we're actually best buddies it's
just that we've been fighting each other
for so long we mistake each other for
our enemies and we're actually not we're
like rival siblings you know they want a
certain thing we want a certain thing
but at least we can all agree on the
rules of the game yeah you know we're
not going to just sit there and slander
each other's character we're not going
to try and
we're not going to try and ruin each
other you know we can respect that we
have a difference of opinion and we can
have a proper conversation the the
extremes of each side don't they hate
you they hate anyone to the the left or
the right of them i mean you know when a
marxist calls you a right winger dave
technically they're right because
anything to the right of them is a right
winger they're so far to the bloody left
i've seen the meme i've seen the meme uh
all right well this one sort of
dovetails on that uh on super chat love
the new center idea how do we not make
the same mistake of purging center
allies for wrong think when we jack
reject the left right fringes so
basically if we if we the center is all
about wrong thinking this is where the
wrong building wrong yeah yeah this is
exactly this is where the wrong thing
happens we sit here we hash out the
ideas and good ideas will naturally rise
to the top bad ideas will just naturally
sink yeah why do you still say that your
left wing when it comes to your
liberalism is more center than anything
i think do you do i'm center-left yeah i
mean like this is why i'm a social
liberal you know i mean i you know i
want universal health care i think a
social safety net is important yeah but
i also agree that thomas sol makes a
good point that an except an excessive
amount of money given creates a perverse
incentive you know i mean and this is
something that happens regularly on
council estates all across the uk yeah
where you'll get young women who think
well i could go and get a career i could
go and get a job that's a lot of work i
could have a few kids out of wedlock and
the government is going to give me that
the conservative party in britain had
cap at 25 000 pounds
the average wage in britain is 22 000
pounds that's a perverse incentive you
can't incentivize people to earn more
money by doing nothing than
the average wage by doing nothing but
having kids yeah i'm sorry it's right
you're actually telling them to do
nothing yeah another from patreon uh can
you explain to a recovering anarchist
how we still get to help people in need
of social help without the government as
it seems to be a ground we could agree
on
this is a good one because that's a
great question actually um
you personally can do it this is one
thing that drives me quick this is this
is what drives me crazier than
bourgeoisie they want the things to be
done they just don't want to do it
themselves and hell i'm kind of that way
as well that's why i'm happy with like a
welfare state and social care i don't
have to worry about those things you
know i mean i could give money to think
but i would rather just not have to and
then i can concentrate on my own
personal selfish interests so is there a
problem is the problem that there's no
real way to test that because i agree i
would rather everyone's taxes be lower
given more money and then you decide if
you want to give to planned parenthood
or if you want to give more to a
homeless shelter or whatever now yes
certain people are just going to give
nothing it's just how it is but
hopefully that would be made up by
people that would for certain things i
think um from and then this is just my
own moral preference so it's it's not
something i could authoritatively say
you need to do x but for certain things
i don't want to see any p any person
sliding through the cracks on say health
care or or housing you know i i loathe
that there are homeless people i mean
the only charity i ever do is giving
money out of my wallet to a homeless
person and i it infuriates me when you
get some bourgeois [ __ ] comes along and
says well he's just gonna spend it on
drugs good
let him spend it on drugs let him spend
on drink he's homeless for christ's sake
yeah meanwhile they're popping pills
left exactly exactly and hypocrisy of it
you know he's only gonna spend it on
drugs get ben you know good i don't care
you know you but and then they'll give
money to some corrupt charity who give
like five percent of it to the actual
people and spend 90 of it on advertising
and wages you know and high salaries for
their you know corporate executives get
ben these people are hypocrites and they
can shut up with a lot of them
all right if you're just joining us we
are doing a a super chat and patreon
chat with carl benjamin sargon of akkad
uh super chat college republicans of fsu
uh was completely destroyed by the alt
left by accusing the president of sexual
harassment and embezzlement why should i
stand up now and risk my future so i
don't know i don't know about the
specific instance of that presumably
you're talking about why should you risk
your future before you finish your
degree yeah and we we addressed that
earlier don't do that finish it do we
just keep your head down i know it you
might feel like you are being oppressed
and you are actually being oppressed by
being forced into silence but this is
just you thinking to your own best
interest you're paying for this degree
don't let them [ __ ] you yeah i i think
that's actually a better answer than
i've i i've always kicked it back to
them and said you know it's on you
to figure out what you have to do and
i've never felt that that answer yeah
was enough but maybe being in this case
like just get your degree and then just
do it don't be a hero don't be here but
once once you've got the degree they
can't take it away from you you know the
problem is do you see the inherent
problem though that then then the same
argument could be well you've now got a
job well no no this this is why then
after you get your degree or your phd or
whatever then you need to become a
professor you need to become one of the
people like brett weinstein who stands
up you know because when it comes to
your job okay that's fine because you
can get another job as a professor
somewhere else and if if a bunch of
angry leftists kick you out of your
university i'm sure that you will be
able to find another job because you'll
become famous you know we will we will
make you famous
no you will not be on your own but the
you have to get into the institutions
you have to get hired as a professor
become part of the institution that they
are now cannibalizing
uh super chat uh great work guys sargon
do you have ideas about how to dress the
mass
muslim migrations to western countries
without violating human rights or
allowing western cultures to diminish so
this is obviously a great question sort
of
as classical liberals i think we've been
caught in the middle of this we don't
want muslim people to be discriminated
against we're trying to have an honest
discussion about the roots of ideology
and extremism
you want to be fair to immigrants
america is a nation of immigrants etc
etc how do you deal absolutely um right
okay
the first thing i would recommend is
controlled immigration uh uncontrolled
mass immigration is dangerous not only
for your social cohesion but it's also a
form of economic warfare against the
poor for a start that's there's the
first argument i'd make but
allowing people in who hold
fundamentally incompatible beliefs
i think is a legitimate form of
discrimination if if you
i mean would you if if
i mean for example if the soviet union
existed would you like allow mass
immigration from the soviet union of all
these communists in that would be crazy
because they would just be advocating
for communism you couldn't do that it's
the same with islam you know if they're
advocating for gender segregation and
the act of oppression of gays and things
like this
you can say no because these go against
the i mean these would be violating the
rights of the people in your society
like they violate the rights of the
people in theirs you don't have to stand
for that and that's not bigoted that's
actually standing for something true on
principle but once they're in
now we're in the position i mean
our hands are well i mean
obviously no one wants to do anything
that's
nasty so i mean my personal i would
maybe provide incentives financial
incentives to you know expatriate or
something like that but again
it's tough and
you get you get certain brands of islam
that are very tribalistic like the
diabandis a pakistani
sect of islam very very close very
tribalistic very anti-western and it's
going to be very very difficult to make
those people integrate and
i mean i don't know i i don't have an
answer to that necessarily beyond that
and right and a liberal tradition really
wouldn't be about forcing them to
believe
something there in life
you know but i mean the the most
important thing i think for people to
engage with them because i mean what one
thing i think we can actually do in this
regard is weaponize the christians
like you've got people like david wood
who he spends his entire youtube channel
knocking down islamic arguments with
remarkable consistency and skill and i
mean i would not agree with david wood
i'm an atheist obviously and i would
never agree with david wood on almost
everything about christianity or the
very principles of religion and why it's
good and why it's necessary and whether
god exists and all that sort of thing
but
i would love to see him absolutely
hammering these muslim apologists and
the um you know the radical preachers
and stuff like debates because he is
going to bring muslims christianity then
more muslims christianity and they're
going to bring christians to islam and i
would rather be around christians who
didn't
want to have a literalist interpretation
of their holy book i would much rather
that yeah you know i think i think
that's honestly the most pragmatic
option can't believe i'm defending
christianity
that's just the whiskey talking all
right super chat would you ever accept
an offer to host your own show similar
to hard talk by a major network i feel
now more than ever uh as you have the
qualifications to do so no all right
moving on uh what creators influenced
you before you got into youtube that's a
good one
a big fan of the four horsemen uh kind
of kind of annoying to see sam harris
floundering at the edges of internet
culture not understanding it not so not
getting the pepe in there no and not not
not just that but like uh i saw him on
uh joe rogan show where he was
complaining about like mike cenovich's
success and stuff like this and i'm
thinking sam you could be like that you
mean don't you don't have to you know
lie or not necessarily like that's
unfair but like distort or misrepresent
you don't have to do that but you just
have to understand
that and sam harris is one of these
pretentious bourgeois liberals he
i mean he literally said i'm looking for
people to get my show but no trolls know
this no that and the other and it's like
sam just stop it just stop with this
pretentious crap get people on who will
be an interesting uh conversa
conversation
just get get someone who will be good
for you to talk to don't if you sit
there and put barriers to entry
frankly of just arbitrary on your part
you're going to find yourself like the
sjws outnumbered by people all around
you that you don't understand you've not
taken the time to engage with them and
that that's the reason the sjws are
losing so it's kind of sad to see like
you know the the last standing horseman
losing losing like the the fight for the
the the platform of ideas you know
interesting no it's it because i i was a
big big respect for the forcement you
know i mean they they were all brilliant
yeah brilliant in their respective
fields excellent arguments you know i
mean i've never been religious but gave
me good arguments to use against the
religious and against um you know
bigotry in general and things like that
in general so it's disappointing to see
sam
kind of turning his nose up about the
other people who like him the most yeah
well without getting into any private
conversations that i've had with him i
i've discussed that with him a little
bit about the the trolling culture and
and that sort of thing yeah
this thing he needs to understand that
it's not
it's not malicious it's um
light-hearted and you know
it just jokes sam calm down
uh okay someone on super chat wants uh
me to take you to in and out instead of
five guys in and out in my humble
opinion here in los angeles he's much
better than five guys so we've actually
got five guys in britain oh you got five
guys yeah i've actually eaten some then
you gotta oh i think it's good all right
you gotta get it no no no no no no no no
well during game again you're going in
and out um
the argument you get from socialists is
look at countries like sweden and norway
thoughts on this so they're not
socialist countries yeah and we've sort
of been yeah but i mean the funniest
thing was when bernie sanders said oh
look at socialist countries like denmark
and the danish prime minister had to
come out and say bernie we're a free
market economy we're not socialist yeah
they're social liberals they're what i
want you know that and there's very
successful because they're social
liberals they're free market economies
they have strong social programs and
they do have high taxes higher than i'm
comfortable with but
they're not marxists they're not
socialist countries right this is this
is the this is the eternal thing the
socialist will always tell you you want
socialized healthcare that's socialism
no socialism is an ideology that has
many different things and it overlaps
with certain other ideologies that also
want similar things that doesn't mean
they're the same and you don't you don't
own socialized health care i'm very
sorry yeah and it's also i think partly
why you've framed a lot of this between
sort of the the freedom side or the
libertarian side and the authoritarian
side yeah i think this is a great
question uh it's for both of us why do
you guys distinguish yourselves as
classical liberals as opposed to regular
libertarians or moderate left or
moderate right no one identifies with
the whigs anymore or any other dead
political parties well that will i'm
sorry the socialists have come right on
back
a hundred years ago they were having
exactly the same conversations that
we're having now i'm sorry we're coming
back
we're coming back to fix this [ __ ]
we have no choice yeah exactly what are
we gonna do do nothing yeah okay
join political philosophies that aren't
gonna work yeah no of course not um
jordan peterson this is super chat
jordan peterson said civilizations go
from order to corruption to the jordan
pizza the jordan p johnson dude i love
you so much he he's great he's great
he's really best
that's interesting so both of us who are
not believers uh oh it's fine yeah i
mean if he wants to hold i mean the
thing is it you know i i don't know why
he holds his beliefs in christianity but
it doesn't bleed into
the rationale for the other beliefs he
holds he's not irrational right his
other beliefs are still rock-solid
and even then you know i can't disprove
god exists it's it's a choice whether
you want to believe or not and you know
i mean i'm not i'm an atheist but i'm
not necessarily anti-theist as long as
it's you know i'm a secularist as long
as they can remain secular i'm happy for
them to remain religious you know
because we both agree that secularism is
the important principle when dealing
with political life but sorry what was
this question uh
the question disappeared actually maybe
oh no uh jordan peterson said
civilizations go from order to
corruption to chaos uh what do you think
about this in relation to our political
climate i mean it's it's kind of yeah um
kind of there
yeah no we're absolutely in that
position now we're we're getting to a
point where the existing order has
become corrupt and it's become
self-serving and that's that's that's
why that's why i wanted trump to win
because i knew it would bring chaos and
chaos is as they famously say a ladder
new things will arise new people will
climb this ladder and get out and bring
something good with them bring something
necessary with them they couldn't climb
the ladder if they didn't have a
solution if they didn't have a new way a
new order that people wanted they
wouldn't have anything that's what i
wouldn't get anywhere i did not vote for
donald trump i did videos on why not to
vote for him i kept saying i don't know
what is moral
i had some of my most the people who i
hold in the highest regards such as sam
on the show to say why not to vote for
him and yet people will still attack me
as some sort of like crazy trump
supporter and it's like i think there's
fertile ground now and there would not
have been fertile ground i tell you what
if if i mean i i i get accused of being
a trump supporter and i'm thinking well
i would hate to have me as a supporter
because my support for trump was trump's
an idiot he's a buffoon but he can get
the job done and that the job is
flipping the table you know show you
know let's let's throw things up in the
air and we'll see where they fall and
we'll build something new out of it and
the same with brexit although brexit was
actually more on points of principle i
genuinely support brexit whereas for me
it was more anti-hillary because hillary
was the apotheosis of all of the
corruption in the system literally i
mean
what wasn't behind hillary that you were
personally opposed to you know goldman
sachs hillary you know mainstream media
hillary other corrupt countries saudi
arabia hillary you know
i'm not supporting any of these things i
want all of these things to fail i have
to support the opposition i should have
videotaped my driving to the polling
station
where i kept saying to david back and
forth for a half hour i have no idea
what i'm going to do right now and then
you've got to carry on i voted for gary
johnson and may i be judged accordingly
uh
he's obviously a nice guy but he's just
not the right guy he's a totally nice
guy he's been on the show i would love
to smoke a joint go skiing with him but
that's oh that sounds great yeah that's
now they're saying what i want out of my
present all right there's so many here
so let's try to knock out a couple quick
patreon who would be a better president
hillary clinton or diane abbott
hillary clinton hands down wow she'd be
corrupt and terrible and awful but she'd
be better she'd be more efficient and
smarter she's brilliant don't get me
wrong she's absolutely brilliant dan
alberts incompetent uh carl i've been
watching christopher hitchen videos
recently and he described himself as a
marxist i know in your opinion how does
he differ from sjw marks is that that's
a good question it's a little in the
weeds but yeah it's a good question uh
it's very much like a linsky describes
himself as a small c communist and
i think i i would have to i mean i would
have to look up why hitchens consider
himself a marxist but i think it's that
he
ideally liked the end goals of what
socialism i mean like what i i recently
read um
the soul of man under socialism by oscar
wilde it's a beautiful piece very very
well written obviously and it's
enjoyable it's it's and it's noble you
know that's the thing there is
definitely no and it was the same with
bertrand russell it's a noble goal that
they're trying to get to
it's never gonna happen they've got no i
mean literally
he thinks i mean he he literally
contradicts himself in the piece where
he says
it you know while man is doing hard
labor like you know sweeping streets in
the rain and stuff like that he can
never fully actualize his personality
because that was the point you know
everyone should be free to be the person
that they are and i completely agree
and that's really really wishful
thinking isn't it because we're never go
i mean when are we ever going to be a
place where mankind doesn't have to
sweep the streets or you know it's going
to be hundreds of years time when
everything's been automated yeah when
that happens brilliant but until then
let's be realistic let's stick with what
works so basically when everything gets
automated then we can reevaluate all of
these positions because yeah like when
we don't have to when we don't have to
labor then socialism will be possible
and in fact it would be inevitable
because there'll be no value to anything
that we do because we didn't put any
effort in to make it it's all there for
us uh is rum and coke a breakfast food
of course of course uh hey sargon and
dave i'm fans of both of you just
curious and sargon's in la are you going
on rogan
uh he's not inviting me have you had any
communication with him i i told him i
was coming if he wants to invite me i'll
happily yeah all right let me see if i
can big fan of john i'll ping him and
see what
um
would you support the uk joining the eu
again if reformed more to the uk
democratic model yeah literally the only
way i would support the uk joining the
eu
is if the uk took over the eu and
started dictating terms
because the
the germans do things differently to the
british the germans like to have an
entire plan and structure put in place
before anything's done and they'd like
to be systematic methodical well thought
out the british aren't like that we're
happy to kind of
bumble along and muddle through and
we're confident that we can make
decisions at the time that they're
sensible and uh it's a it's not that the
germans are wrong and we're right or
we're right and you know and vice versa
it's just different yeah and it's not
compatible especially not compatible
with what we consider to be freedom man
if you guys are bumbling through i
really don't know what we're doing over
here that's awesome oh you didn't sing
it's a whole lot exciting uh this is
interesting one sargon are you familiar
with any of ayn rand's works and do you
have any thoughts on objectivism you
know i've actually never read anything
by iran um i like her argument that the
smallest minority is the individual
because that a works in our favor
because it's definitely against
collectivism um
but no i as far as i'm aware they're a
bit um
a bit too hard line i i mean i know
something of what she was saying um
but no i've never i've never looked into
rand i've never felt the need yeah
interestingly i did an event with them
uh with the iran institute last weekend
and
i said to them look if we can fully
agree on free speech i can say whatever
i want when i'm up there and we're just
going to completely agree on the
absolute need for free speech i'll be
happy to work with you they said we'll
put all anything else aside and work
with you on that and i thought that's
how you build allies so i'm happy yeah
i'm sorry i've been going to colleges
with them and i'm happy i can work with
anyone who can agree on certain
principles and that's one of them uh
what is the future of your channel will
you branch out to something else like
the brown buffalo did
no
eventually i plan to retire maybe maybe
i'll write a novel that's crap or maybe
make a video game that's crap like i
wanted to before i did my channel yeah
very good i don't want to do any of this
uh sargon i'm a long time fan of your
channel have recently started my own
youtube channel similar to yours you
should have given yourself a shout out
any advice for a recent startup what was
his name he uh i only have the questions
here oh oh sorry i'd like to give you a
shout out yeah um any advice um
read
read read books read books that you can
be sure are written by experts
absorb as much of the knowledge as you
can and apply it in what you're doing
and i mean i mean literally you have to
put in the hard work you can't just sit
there and i mean i i half-assed it for
about a year and a half before i was
like right i'm just going to buckle down
and act like i'm getting a degree in
this or something and actually read the
literature and you and
gary edwards is a youtuber and a
philosophy professor and i have a lot to
thank for him because i was quoting
aristotle's like you know what it's even
better if you read it in the context
right and i was like all right all right
i'll get off my ass i'll do the work and
it was worth it you know it's funny i uh
i you do have to read these things
because although i have read some iron
rand i kept using that the smallest
minority is the individual quote i kept
attributing it to ion hersey ali who has
said really and then finally people kept
saying to me it was ran not not ion um
let's see oh this is interesting
thoughts on compulsory military or civil
service from a classical liberal slash
individualist perspective the the whole
like individual's perspective as long as
everyone has to do it it's not
anti-individualist because that's the
whole point of individualism it doesn't
leave anyone outside of the purview of
what it's doing it applies to everyone
equally and so it's completely
individualist i'm actually not
necessarily against compulsory military
service i i think that it would probably
do the bourgeoisie a lot of good to get
down in the trenches metaphorically
unless there's a war obviously but get
get down in the barrack rooms with the
working class and get to know them
because that's the problem they don't
understand these people they don't
understand the lack of pretensions of
the working class the working class they
can't afford pretensions you know
they've got nothing to be pretentious
about yeah they've got they've got real
things to work yeah exactly they've got
real problems and it's it's only from
living with them that i understand that
they have real problems they're not
pretentious people and you can't afford
to be pretentious and and this is why i
hate the board
it's so annoying uh i'm a leftist but i
don't think identity politics is a core
issue and would rather focus on things
like ending austerity and ending
dependency on fossil fuels how do we
take progressivism back that's
interesting because i would argue it's
too late i don't think there is any
taking it back i think it's incompatible
with what we want yeah you know what
what
what progressives want will also happen
under liberalism yeah you know this is
the overlapping magisteria i was talking
about earlier for example like gay
rights what's the argument against gay
rights there is none it's a religious
argument therefore we have gay rights
anyone can get married i mean if we just
have
if we just have the thing rather than
who can do the thing i mean for example
abortion men should be able to get
abortions they won't
they won't patients patients but one day
maybe they will i mean i don't know what
will happen in 200 years time you know
who knows well gender is a social
contract yeah exactly but um and
biological sex might go that way too but
it there's no reason to distinct to
discriminate against men because that
just means at some point in the future
if for some fluke or chance or weird
exemption to the rule that some you know
a man happens to actually need an
abortion the law will prevent him from
doing so it's like why what difference
does it make if it's men and women who
can get you know it's it's that kind of
thing if we just focus on the thing
itself what can people do people can do
x people can do why
why put any kind of proviso on that as
to some state you know i mean the only
the only exception i can do that is sort
of like financial situation but that's
not something inherent to yourself so
you know
i hear you uh dave and carl what
happened to atheist youtube with jordan
peterson causing huge waves for
christians why haven't these youtube
channels addressed
jordan peterson's views on god that's
interesting well sam and him have had
two talks one was really hard to listen
to and they couldn't get there the
second one they think in different ways
right they just but the second one they
they got much closer to it i would love
to host both of them here but do you
think that atheist youtube whatever that
is defined as has maybe missed an
opportunity to
push back on his i don't feel the need
personally i don't i don't feel that
secularism is under threat i
i don't feel that jordan peterson's
religiosity has anything
is a threat to my secularism at all i
don't see the need to fight it i think
the battle has been won you know the the
christian fundamentalists and i'm not
saying pizza is one yeah the christian
fundamentalists have lost the argument
we're not we're not going down that road
we're not enforcing things on the basis
of real religion and when you know i
don't i don't see anyone actively i
don't see anyone like really
um advancing that cause so i'm not
worried about it so in a way the
enlightenment be the enlightenment and
liberalism in a lot of ways beat
christianity yeah and now it now it has
a different a different enemy so to
speak yeah but ironically i mean they
share a lot of the same values i mean
jesus was not um
he wasn't a collectivist he was an
individualist he he he was a
universalist that you know there's
it's it's really the american right that
caused the problem with christianity and
it came from this excessive moralizing
and well they lost the argument yeah
well it really came from just a
way to win elections that uh karl rove
figured let's really get in bed with the
christian conservatives and make this
happen with george w bush but that's a
whole other story uh sargon what are
your thoughts on george soros
big fan i would imagine he's a he's a
hugely intelligent man highly educated
you don't become a billionaire without
being at least
intelligent in some way
but he's if you look at him he's very
well educated
and he has a plan and i think that this
plan is very detrimental to the lowest
in the societies that we have
but he considers
i think he considers people outside of
our societies to be even lower and
that's you know and the socioeconomic
acts as they are
but he his solutions are very
detrimental to our own working classes
very detrimental um
and i think they're just completely
wrong he's not evil
he just has a conception of the world
but he thinks he can make it
and it's not the one i agree on fair
enough you went kind of easy on him i
thought that was going to be yeah i know
i thought that was gonna be a full
tearing i wanted to be realistic you
know
i could i could get polemic on it yeah
uh if extremes like corbin are on the
fringes of society why are they growing
in popularity is it because people are
angry at the current state of affairs so
i think we sort of hit that already it's
it's not that i mean they were on the
fringe of society and then the center
got neo-liberal because i mean listening
another thing that's important to
remember we're not neo-liberals
we don't agree that vast corporations
should be able to meddle with government
absolutely they shouldn't they shouldn't
be able to exploit the the poor and in
other nations you know the
these are these are things that is a and
these are problems with liberalism this
is something we have to be vigilant
about the first thing as soon as if we
can get like a liberal party in
government the first thing we've got to
do is smash the influence of
corporations over our governments we i
mean i personally would be quite radical
about it and i would say something like
right i mean i i would be
brutal with any politician who took
money from anywhere other than the
public purse yeah i would be brutal
about it so is it
like literally like life
we are talking
i mean the harshest punishment we can
find for anyone who takes any corporate
money is the worst corporations are fine
if they exist it's fine they're made up
of individuals who all vote they will
they can all individually donate to
parties and whatnot but to have like
this sort of corporate pandering that
politicians are all bought and paid for
it's the worst that's corrupted our
society to completely do you see that as
a bit of a catch-22 though because you
don't want to exert too much state
influence over things or you think that
this one is so corrupting in a sort of
holistic way yeah it's it's too
dangerous but what i'm i'm not actually
advocating we all influence the
corporations themselves i want to put
rules on the politicians
if you take money from these sources
then you are in trouble they they
you're this right the corporations can
do their thing exactly they're always
going to be corrupting influences and
they're always going to be trying to
corrupt the important the legislators
themselves so it's the legislators we
have to make sure they understand they
are the bulwark against these corrupting
influences you know and the fact they're
not at the moment and in fact it's okay
at the moment i mean i've i've never
taken any corporate money in my channel
in my entire life you know the entire
existence of my channel has been
entirely crowdfunded through either ad
revenue and views or patreon or you know
individual donations or merchandise
sales you know
small business you know that's the thing
the idea of taking corporate backing is
horrific to me it stands against
everything i stand for but it's not that
corporate backing in and of itself is
wrong yeah it's that i want to and i
don't say remain pure but i can't think
of a better way of expressing that i got
religious real quick i know right but i
want to i want to maintain that i can i
can always say look there is no chance
of these factors being an influence over
me because i am dead set against them
and i completely agree with chenk and
the the justice democrats i completely
support even everyone worries the
justice democrats are going to go
suddenly full sjw okay so what if they
do so what if they go for sjw they're
still going to be against money and
politics corporate money and politics
that is a noble goal and we should
support it regardless whether we agree
or not if they were full-on christians
like you know religious like
christian types i would still support
their efforts to try and get corporate
money out of politics because it has to
happen but we can't get that
conversation happening while everyone's
going yeah but what about the white
people are the black people
[ __ ] the white and black people i don't
care
oh this is my identity oh that's
interesting actually it's not get out uh
yeah uh what are sargon and dave's views
on the limits of free speech on the you
in the uk uh in light of youtuber count
dankula's situation so i i don't know
about that one specifically uh hashtag
free countdown
please um there is no justification for
a man going to court
over what is just a [ __ ] post i mean he
you know there's obviously i i bet you
couldn't find a single person who
thought he legitimately was promoting
nazism i bet you couldn't find one no
one no one in their right mind is going
to stand up and say you know what this
is him promoting nazism because he
taught for anyone doesn't know he taught
his girlfriend's dog to zig heil
which obviously is a joke and it was in
he literally says in the video he's
doing it to piss off his girlfriend
unbelievable and he might go to jail for
that i mean that's truly unbelievable
all right super chat hey sargon do you
agree or have seen the 10 natural
occurring rules for the skeptic
community by liz reptile in short it's a
rule for how the skeptic community
should uh conduct in manner of discourse
um no but i imagine liz has thought it
through because i know liz reptile she's
a youtuber yeah um and you guys should
all check her out she's honest yeah
that's the thing she's honest and
reliable
i imagine they're probably fairly
sensible i haven't looked i haven't seen
them though so don't quote me on that uh
why do britons accept the absurd notion
that brexit is a negotiation brexit
means we're out we're leaving and we
don't need your permission
fear-mongering from the
left it's disgusting yeah i mean
they keep going on about a soft brexit
that will keep us inside the single
market the customs union
then we're not leaving the european
union yeah and it's also not a democracy
in a certain way at that point well
what's worse is we also don't have a say
over the european union right so we're
staying
all we're doing is ceding our own power
to the european union it's ridiculous we
have to leave them and what's even more
frustrating is how oh but it might end
up that we'll end up with no deal no we
will end up with a deal because billions
of pounds and euros are at stake and
none of the people involved want to lose
billions of pounds in euros they will
all come to a deal they'll come to a
compromise it will be fine don't worry
about the fear-mongering all right for
those just playing along we got about 10
more minutes q and a with sargon of
akkad uh jeff back to patreon can we
have a center when the center won't hold
what would a center ideology look like
so i think we got that mostly there the
second ideology would be a broad liberal
the very base of it is
we're not going to call each other names
that's that's what it's basically got to
be founded on we're not going to accuse
each other of being evil yeah and we can
the most we can really do is accuse each
other of being wrong and when you say oh
you're wrong
why am i wrong then you have to explain
yourself then a discussion happens it's
it's this is the problem with each
extreme they accuse each other of being
evil that's a useless term do you find
when you get involved in the [ __ ]
posting and all that stuff that that in
a way can be seen as getting away from
that value you know what i mean like if
you're really mocking the hell out of
somebody sometimes on twitter by the way
i'm not judging you for it no no no no
no i'm fine all these platforms are
different in a way oh yeah absolutely
i'm slightly different on twitter than i
am here so but do you ever find that
that is a bit of a sort of shaving of
the of that idea like on twitter you're
going to mock some people
mockery's fine you know mockery isn't
saying someone that you're illegitimate
you know in fact you would only ever
mock someone whose views are legitimate
you know you never mock like
you know i don't i don't make videos
about
like i don't know alex jones you know
his views aren't legitimate they're
crazy views you know and so i don't need
to talk about them i don't need to mock
them i don't need in fact i enjoy alex
jones because of how crazy they are you
know i'm always like jesus what is he
going to say next you know
there's no need to mock it because it's
funny on the face of it you can only
mark things that are sensible you know
or at least at least have a logical
foundation even if they're completely
wild and wrong have you seen oliver
stone's interview of putin and what's
your opinion of putin as the leader of
russia
putin is a great statesman he's a very
clever man he understands power politics
and he's a russian nationalist he's a
patriot
he's not a good man and you shouldn't
expect your leaders to be good men uh
especially if they come from
authoritarian countries like russia same
with assad you know these these are not
good people morally but they are
efficient people and
they
do have an ethical standard that they
adhere to is in the benefit of their own
people and that unfortunately comes at
the detriment of others and in that can
include some people who become a threat
to their own position in the country i
know this is going to get misinterpreted
as me saying putin's a good man
no he's not on a moral level he's
undoubtedly highly immoral like uh
lipvenko and
undoubtedly dozens of journalists
probably have disappeared
but unfortunately that's the nature of
being an autocrat it's not my choice i
don't like autocracy that's why i'm in
favor of democracy but um
you know i'm not it's just the way life
is how would you suggest opening the
mind of an indoctrinate indoctrinated
normie about the toxic ideology of sjws
their hypocrisy and the outrage machine
keeping oppression relevant in a modern
western society i mean what's the best
way to pin to open that door it depends
on the individual it depends what they
care about um
i i guess you could look at it through
political philosophy um for example if
if you're talking to a socialist the
best thing to do is hit them
economically so explain to them look
show me where socialism has made people
richer because they'll never do it
they'll never tell you that socialism
will make the poor wealthy if it's not
going to make the poor wealthy what good
is it you know your problem is the poor
are too poor and they can't get anywhere
well that's not going to help them is it
you know you've got to attack them on
the access that they're concerned about
so like and
like uh
i
name another political philosophy but
you've got you've got to you've got to
attack them on the things that they put
forward you have to refute rather than
providing something that's not directly
challenging them um so yeah you've got
to know the person basically uh this is
super chat tommy robinson recently said
that the people will start forming
militias to address the islam problem in
britain
how likely do you think that is
i think we're some way off from militias
at the moment but we've just had our
first
uh right-wing anti-muslim terrorist yeah
um
and the guy did say you know i
kill all muslims i've done my part so
it's not i don't think it will happen i
think it will happen and i
i mean you know i think we're way off
from it yet but
eventually i mean you know we're having
terror attacks all the time in europe
you know you can't go a week without an
islamic terror attack
if you don't think that has to something
has to be done about that you're insane
and you're
you are just detached from reality and
it's not because i hate muslims or i
give a [ __ ] it's because i'm looking at
the objective reality that people will
do something yeah you know they're going
to do something it's not whether i think
good or bad what do you think is going
to happen well i think the right wing is
going to come and do something terrible
so let's jump in before they do let's
you know what's the problem well
usually radical hate preachers in
mosques and the um the the
couple of professors from the i think it
was university college london had
basically done a study on this and they
spent eight years or something tracking
all of this they were like look people
are getting ready radicalized from the
internet they're getting interested in
radicalization from the internet what it
takes is like um a personal connection
with someone so it's when they go to the
mosque and then they speak to the right
they get they hear isis propaganda they
go to the mosque speak to the radical
hate preacher who's saying basically the
same thing and he effectively recruits
them into a network which is essentially
what andy chowdhury didn't know all the
frenchbury park mosque boys did
so it's it's that nexus that we have to
hit because these are the guys preaching
hate you know and imam tawidi made a
good point it's like he he went down to
his local market in australia and got an
al-qaeda flag it's like jesus christ you
know you may as well be selling
swastikas you know it's exactly the same
thing and so
yeah we need to hit the the preachers
and the people you know actually
disseminating this nonsense all right
we're going to go about four more
minutes with carl right here and then
we're going to do a rapid-fire segment
on patreon i'm i am just taking full-on
advantage of you as yourself that's all
right you're slightly jet-lagged i i'm
i'm quite jealous i've had like five
hours sleep in the last like 36 hours
you seem to have a serious command of
the issues for someone with a whiskey
and not that much sleep i've been
thinking about it a lot
a lot um
uh hey carl love your content how would
you say your political statements have
affected your personal relationships if
at all no not at all all of my friends i
honestly my political positions haven't
really changed yeah i know i i decided
that um and that's the thing i i
reasoned myself into my politics you
know i i mean my parents were not really
very political at all they weren't
religious
and so the concern was about
interpersonal relationships and and this
is this is the thing that um drives me
crazy is the concept of personal honor
has been completely destroyed in the
west and i don't understand why if if
you're going to treat someone else with
respect why should you expect respect in
return and that supersedes in my opinion
any political position i i will happily
have a polite conversation with a
neo-nazi or a communist or anyone i find
despicable on an ideological level
because it's more important in my
opinion
to have the polite conversation and to
be able to actually have a dialogue you
know and to show if you show respect to
someone else then regardless of what
their ideology tells them to do they
will find themselves hindered doing
anything to you from their personal
respect to you that's what honor is and
so it's i think that's more important
than politics but yeah my parents were
broadly apolitical and so i
i mean i i read das capital and i felt
myself getting a bit socialist when i
was like 22 or something and then i read
nietzsche and thus like spoke to the
hour through stream i didn't know what
to make because i didn't understand it
at the time and um
and yeah and and so over the years i've
basically just been thinking about it
and thinking well i think you know like
liberalism is the best and it's the most
reliable and
the safest structure for human rights we
and for for what i consider to be the
correct proper value system yeah i i
couldn't agree more all right let's try
to knock out a couple real quick um
if there was a centrist party in the uk
would you try to lead it oh no i don't
against politics done um uh will someone
want to know the top five books that we
would both want them to read that relate
to this i mean on liberty to me is is
the one right um i yeah wrote serfdom
and uh
yeah i mean honestly it's it's not
really liberalism you have to read to
understand social justice that's the
thing you need to read like the prince
you need to read um
uh
well what's playing olinsky's one oh
rules for rap rules yeah so you're you
that's interesting so your argument is
read their [ __ ] basically well no that's
not their [ __ ] that's the thing right
power politics is an entirely separate
lens it underlies everything that
everyone does but nobody understands it
um read yes so read the prince read
rules for radicals read robert greene 48
laws of power 33 um
33 wow what the hell was the name i
can't remember i i'm a real lightweight
and i'm i'm feeling kind of like yeah
you're doing fine you're doing better
but basically yeah so those and then
read something historical i mean
plutarch anything by plutarch is
fantastic because that gives you um
he was an ancient moralist and he
beautiful read and maybe that's just my
personal preference but yeah i think
also just on a broad sense just knowing
some history not even political
philosophy i don't understand the
history because when i would when i was
in it with the progressives i would have
conversations with people that were
public people and we'd start talking
history and i'd go man
you don't know basic
history i'm not just talking american
history i'm talking history of the
middle east of europe like just basic
stuff know some basic stuff so that your
arguments have some
value what's interesting about history
is that almost all of like political
history that you read is actually the
history of power politics you know what
you're reading is the interactions of
rulers and nations with each other and
that gives you the fundamental education
of what power politics is and it's
important because it's in everywhere
it's in everyone's lives they just don't
really understand it and don't really
think about it and it's it's cruel as
well that's the thing people have got to
understand that you can't
you can't expect interpersonal
interactions to go along that line and
when you see someone who is like the
social justice warriors everything they
do is power politics and they don't even
realize it they don't even realize it
but look at the definitions what's
racism
prejudice plus power that's everything
sexism prejudice plus power everything
about it is power politics and i don't
think they understand it but if you
understand history you understand
olinsky robert greene
machiavelli
and if you're a liberal read you know
whatever you know whatever liberal
classical liberal authors you want um
then you can understand why they think
what they think even if they don't
well said all right i want to end us
here on a big one
um
there's a lot about centrist parties
that seems to be a big theme now people
want us to run
centrist candidates uh okay oh this is a
good one because i think it encapsulates
a lot of what we do do you think that
mainstream journalism will ever recover
the fact that that people come to people
like us now for news or for opinion or i
think it'll be people like tim paul in
the future i think he's he's he gets a
lot of support on patreon and on youtube
and with good reason because he is an
actual journalist and i i love seeing
him on twitter he's about where we were
like about a year ago 30 years ago yeah
where he's just like jesus christ
journalism is awful it's just activism
it's like yes dude
yes you know that's all it is these days
it's about trying to get you to believe
something rather than telling you what's
happened and allowing you to make your
own decisions and draw your own
conclusions and i think it'll be people
like tim paul but don't wrong it's going
to take a long time before that happens
you know the institutions that we have
now they're powerful they're built up
they've got a lot of money they get the
stories first a lot of the time they go
to the places but you know independent
journalists like temple do the same and
you have to support these people and i
mean i
you know it the important thing as well
is like as much as i love lauren
southern and i'd like lauren southern a
lot you can see how she's crossing into
activism because she's feeling morally
compelled to do something unfortunately
as a journalist you have to stand
outside of that and let's not say that
what she does isn't valuable yeah
because it is but it's it's
for a political ideology rather than for
the objective collection of knowledge
yeah i wonder you know i've had her on
the show i wonder if
i said to her you know flat out do you
consider yourself an activist at all is
your journalism i think she should
understand that what she does is
activision as well as journalism i'm
sure she would which also shows that the
rules have just changed to the point
where someone that that's her that maybe
is a little more of an activist than a
journalist or both or whatever i don't
want to speak for her that there's a
space for that now oh yeah it's not it's
not because everyone's doing it
it's not invalid or anything you know i
mean there's nothing wrong with doing
activism yeah um
but i think the the real journalism the
real like you know the scoops will come
from people like tim paul who understand
objectivity neutrality and the
presentation of information honestly is
more important than academic because
when you when you when you're doing
activism uh that's sort of sliced in
with journalism there will come a time
where you
find yourself skewed in favor of the
activism rather than the journalism
because the journalism contradicts what
you want your activism to be right you
know and that's your bias yeah those
things have to come in confidence
exactly
yeah i'm you know what i love i honestly
i love tim paul's work because he
is just giving me the facts he just
gives me the information and i will make
the decision of what i think the
interpretation of that is and that is
what we need more of i think that
eventually will be the future but it's
gonna be a long way to get there and the
the establishment that we have now i
mean that the the the wall street
journal and the times attacking youtube
that's just the beginning they're gonna
keep going so if you're if you have a
favorite like i mean like literally you
don't need to support me i i you know my
the people who bagged me on patreon and
buy my shirts and stuff i don't need any
more support there's people like tim
paul the and it's not even tim paul
temple's doing great as well it's the
next journalist who's like look i'm
gonna go somewhere or like luke without
school whatever these guys who are going
to actually go there because i am a fat
lazy bastard i don't want to go anywhere
it took me a long time to come here and
you know take a long time coming i don't
want to go anywhere i don't want to do
anything i'm happy to talk about what
other people find but it's the folks who
are going to get off their houses and
actually get to those places support
those people yeah donate to their
patrons well said brother i'm glad we
did this actually in real life
and by the way you're you ended the
first hour on a beautiful sort of you
brought it all together very nicely you
ended this by giving a shout out to tim
who i did two hours with today by
complete coincidence yeah i didn't i was
actually trying to work it so i didn't
have to do both of these on the same day
uh so i guess i guess there is something
that's been happening oh yeah i think
there's something i the the woke
centrists are getting woke yeah all
right and for the rest of you guys
thanks for watching all day four hours
of this stuff i i hope you enjoyed it
and i'm guessing most of you know where
to find uh carl on the youtube but just
put sargon is it just slash sargon of
akkad yeah or just sargon into google
and i'm the first thing that comes up
i'm so sorry historical yeah i'm so
sorry
all right well thank you carl aka sargon
of akkad and uh let's get some beers and
some uh you know a burger but we're
gonna do it oh yeah all right all right
thanks everybody
[Music]
you